Great overlap. Do you drink?
Do you want to zero alcohol?
Caniquan sure. If you have it. One.
Yeah. There you go. Phil. Zero alcohol.
Let's get crazy. Excellent pace
ourselves. She takes cheers, sir.
I'm going chug this. Whoa. Don't do not
get to that too dangerous. Zero alcohol.
How many calories though? We scare
calories, Bro. You stay alive.
That's trying to get plenty of
calories already. I have to ask you,
did you drive it in the Hemi? No, I
didn't. I got dropped off in a Chevy.
Oh my God. This is outrageous.
I had one for a little while.
It's just a little while.
Yeah,
I figure like you would have to have one
for quite a long time. It was fun. Well,
okay, I'm going to backtrack a little
bit. So first commercial, right, that,
thank God I hear me right.
I did six of these things and
around commercial three I,
uh, I was talking to my agent
and I said, man, you know,
if they ask you to do another
one, oh shit. Here we go. Yeah.
That's the worst I've
ever looked at my life.
I really felt like I was sitting in a
desert like no one's ever going to see
these commercials, and I wasn't going
to know what a Hammy is incorrect.
I could not have been more
wrong. Yeah, there it is.
Look at that bad.
I asked you,
did they give you one or did you just go
out and buy one? Well, I said, listen,
if they,
if they want me to do another commercial,
see if you can get a vehicle out of them.
Right in. My agent was like, you know,
make it their problem. He calls him up. He
goes, hey, I don't know if you know this,
but your Hamy Guy,
your spokesman is driving
around Los Angeles right now
and a Suzuki sidekick. Oh.
And they're like,
what's my name is
not the fucking die.
So at the same thing,
it's the lightest.
It's a box Skype.
If you could put a string to it
and float it in the years that,
that shitty looking jeep thing. Yes. Oh
Wow. You have one of those? I did read.
I don't know why.
For some reason I liked that thing.
I've got it in college and
as my way like it. Yeah.
It was cool for a tailgating and
shit. There it is. Yeah, that's,
that's the ll cool j versus, I
didn't have that one. Let's see. No,
I think I saw that in a video one time
cause that's, that's the one I had. Right.
You've got that hard top. Damn. Yeah.
I had total that thing in North
Dakota one time hit black ice.
I mean a gust of wind just knocked
me off the road and I was in a ditch,
but it was, uh, you know
how people in motorcycles,
they'll see another
motorcycle and they'll wave.
It's like a little club that
you're in and jeeps do it too.
And I started doing that to others who
Zukie sidekicks and out of port for a
reason, I'd wave to them nine times out
of 10. It's like a overweight black lady.
And I just went with that and I'm
like, what does he do it? I was like,
we're in the club man. So, but yeah, uh,
people like Nice cars, but to do that
with shitty cars too. Yeah. That's what,
that's the next level that's more fun.
Like I see you,
did they give you when they give
you a hemming? It was a, uh, uh,
1500 dodge ram quad cab black lot of
chrome feel comfortable on it then I loved
it. I loved when I first got it. You know,
it's like, it's like in the middle of,
you know,
I did six of those commercials.
So as ride around La with the windows
down, just blasting, you know,
Leonard Skinner and shit. Yeah.
The comedy store and like park it,
I made, they hated park in that
thing and that then that lot,
because it's gigantic, it's a
wide and they're like, really man,
can you just have somebody drop you off?
Brendan chavs been showing up in his, uh,
he got a raptor.
Oh yeah.
Realize how wide those things are
until he's standing in front of him.
Like huge as a fucking giant vehicle
and then trying to valet that thing
anywhere in Los Angeles.
You know,
it's a lot of tiny little Mexican
dudes are like, really man.
Well the worst is if you
try to valet a stick shift.
I tried to give a valley my keys to my
bronco and he didn't know what to do.
I go, you don't know how to drive
a stick shift. He goes, no. I go,
what the fuck are you doing here man?
How can you have this job? Yeah. Yeah.
That should be a part of the a resume.
I can't drive all cars. It's crazy.
Yeah. My, I don't think most
people know how to, you know,
and do what an under 30 could drive
a stick. I don't think so. No.
Going into is going gone. Yeah.
Porsche doesn't make them any more.
The only American muscle cars were one
of the last holdouts like corvette and
Camaro. I haven't driven a stick
in a long time mustangs. You know,
you want to try? Sure. Today
actually, the last time I did,
I was in Costa Rica and I rented,
I rented a car and I'm like,
I just assume all cars now when you
rent them are automatics. You know,
you get to know the country. It's, it's
what ever, and so I'm pulling out of the,
uh, the lot and it's like, oh shit. It's
been admitted. It was pretty embarrassing.
I got this. Yeah. When you're in
Italy, they all drive stick shifts.
Even like minivans. Yeah.
It's weird. Yeah. Everything's
a stick shift over there.
I'm not sure why. I don't know. What,
what's the advantages and disadvantages?
I mean, what do you prefer? Well,
if I was in where I was in Italy,
it was in Ravello,
which is a very small little roads.
It's very tiny and it's like
crazy congestion because
of tourism. Yeah. And uh,
the guy was always on the clutch back and
forth, back and forth. I was like, yeah,
this is, you gotta be annoying as fuck.
You'd be having automatic just like La,
right? Like if you're in,
if you're commuting to la
bumper to bumper every day,
you're going to want an automatic
exact, that's what happened, right?
I think you're right. Yeah. Yeah.
It's just more comfortable
lip lift the car to the work.
But if you're on a mountain road,
like the angel's Crest Highway,
Oh yeah.
You want to shift.
There's something cool about being in
command of the vehicle and you killing it
when it's manly. Yeah. It is,
and he got a dick in your hand and
if it's a woman, I've got to go, Ooh,
don't get too close to this one. Yeah.
She likes driving stick shifts like, well,
she's a rebel.
Right.
She might be great in bed
maybe. Yeah. For a little while.
And then I didn't bring her house.
She gets mad at you for email for 12
years ago.
I didn't even know you that what the fuck?
I can't go back and find this. Where's
that phone come from? That's a flip phone.
Zukie sidekick. We were looking at
that thing from ces at Jamie pulled up.
What does that goofy thing called?
These are good, right? I'll really,
I don't feel like I'm drinking
a nonalcoholic, it tastes
like a regular beer. Um,
planet computers. Cosmo
communicator, which is like,
it's outside of thing that is,
that is wasted.
Someone was doing coke and they decided,
is that having a space ship? It does.
It looks at it lucky. These has a planet
or a spaceship on the front of it.
It looks like one of those metal wallets
that you get to keep your credit cards.
Yeah. But that shit is
preposterous. Missing your fingers.
Who makes that fat? Fucking hands am
not going to fit on that thing. Yeah.
He's not going to be able to do that at
this point. We're so used to doing this.
Why go back and go to back to that now?
Do you ever go sideways in your iPhone?
Uh, yeah. Just to take a picture.
Yeah, but never a typing. No Way.
I thought that was the move. I'm
like, oh, once we go sideways,
that's going to be the shit.
Have you tried on an iPad?
Uh, have not. It's not bad.
Yeah. Sideways. Yeah. Like when you
have to type on the full screen,
the full cohort of hands. Not
Bad. Yeah. It's not perfect,
but it's way better than just your thumbs
on an iPhone. Yeah, that makes sense.
Especially if you can type, I used to
think I would never get used to that.
Just that you know the, the,
the screen without feeling it.
Look at that little front screen.
Like you've got a bunch of
shit that comes in on it.
Look at that whole like apps and
stuff. I guess. Boy that's going to,
no one's buying that song. How am
I gonna do that thing? How much is,
there are so many options now.
If you don't like apple and you're
committed to like an android phone,
there's so many options. Why
would you buy that thing? What?
I don't even know what
companies that whom exactly.
That's also part of the problem,
right? Yeah. That'll be gone.
Like where do you bring that
thing to get it fixed? Yeah.
If the screen cracks and you bring
it to the mall, what is it? Yeah,
the cosmo communicated,
Bro.
I'm going to have to go to the
future and fix this thing. Yeah.
We can't do this in 10 minutes.
This thing's a mess. I mean,
I got a cracked screen now and you know,
it's not even that bad,
but I've seen people walk around with
like damn spiderweb on their phone.
I'm like, when are you going to
go get it fixed? What's the point?
It's the glass was falling off.
This is an indication of you needed to
get your shit together. Yeah, that's true.
Yeah. If your phone looks like a like
a haunted house. That's a good one.
Yeah. Let's go into like, uh, you know,
see if those girls going to be crazy.
How cracked is her screen? That's a
good point. Like gimme your phone,
like a girl who can deal with a little
crack. That's probably the, okay.
She's cool. Just a little crack in
the window in the corner. No big deal.
It'll fine. She doesn't give
a fuck. She's easy going.
She doesn't even need to wear makeup bro.
You know what if he's had to do like
this and get the light just right cause
it's like a dam.
It's a full [inaudible] get tea
because that part of the glass won't work.
What about the other way they're
going with the flex phone?
Because this isn't the one that broke,
but this is another one that came out at
ces to that they'd read called Samsung
recalled the ones, I suppose they
were called all of them. Huh?
They'd unreleased date.
Now they're not going to,
who knows when they're to come
out and they break in like crazy.
Apparently flex phone. Is
it flexible bins? Yeah.
But how does that one work? All I'm seeing
is like, yeah, opened up video of that.
Yeah. The Samsung one had
like a little teeny, uh,
I don't know if you look online in the
each slash aquarium that we put sea
monkeys in, it does, right? It
looks like one of them ones.
It's like a pillar and a shitty hotel
in Miami or somewhere by full for hours.
Someone needs to clean the tank.
They have a waterway,
has a flexible and it looks way
better than the Samsung one.
It looks thinner and it looks like they
just nailed the design better and on the
side of it. What's it? Yeah, it's
a different car. I don't know. No,
no, no. Sorry. Royale Flex Pie beat
Samsung. And why wait? A market sells out.
That's what this one was folded.
Folded in half. Yeah. Yeah. They're,
they're making these things where you
can flex them and bend them like a
thousand times. Oh, how
weird. Yeah. That's weird.
How am I supposed to fat? That
thing is, that's like Karen,
a VHS tape in your pocket. Right. I mean,
I'm trying to imagine the advantages and
disadvantages of watching porn on that
thing. Oh, there's advantages. Yeah.
Cause like Lassi your ass and then you
got to turn your phone upside down.
That's pretty wild how it
works. That is eight. Yeah.
Well kind of hoping it works so that
the version three or four in a couple of
years, it's way better than
these broken ones. Well for sure.
You're going to see people
at concerts holding a blue,
it looks like 12 inch iPads because it's
going to be these goddamn things in the
future. I've seen that before. Now
would you do that? Because they're
assholes. Yeah. They're everywhere.
I mean you're right. Yeah. I hate
it. Especially like a comedy show.
It's like the, the
phones bad enough. I pad,
I have a Tesla and uh,
the Tesla has this huge screen.
Right. It's enormous. Yeah. Yeah.
And you get so used to it. Yeah.
So I go from that to another car with a
little tiny navigation screen like that.
Is this bullshit? Yeah. It's funny
how you get used to things. It's like,
I'd rather have a Thomas Guide when I
first did you have on those and he came to
la. God, he had to pull
over every five feet.
Bill Burr had one of those
as recently as 2011 wow.
Came to my house. I really came
to my house in his fucking Prius.
He still has a Prius.
That asshole that's probably got $1
billion is going to fuck it. Prius.
He pulls into my driveway and a, I see
the Thomas Guide is backseat. He's like,
yeah, those that navigation
shit with that goes down.
You can't figure your way around town.
Yeah. You're lost up in the hills.
No connection. The Thomas Guy Works
every time I knew how to do it, man.
I get back in the day.
Oh Ie 10 I know how to do that.
You go eat 10 that's why I
need to go write it down.
And that was always dangerous.
Fuck up.
And all of a sudden you're
in a Mexican community.
Chickens or run across this street.
Sounds great.
Is Sun Valley sketch never been to
Sun Valley? I think it is. Yeah.
There's lots of, I'd been there once.
I got to think I got lost. I was like,
this is, this is not. So when you got
rid of your Hemi, did you say, hey,
this is from the Hemi guy,
like this should be worth
some money? Oh well it was,
I thought a kid like auction
at all. Yeah, on Ebay.
Like I took pictures with it and
everything. It didn't work. It was like,
I think it was when gas was at its
highest price and paper. Like no,
I think we're moving on to other things.
So fucking high,
no it's closing in on
five bucks a gallon again.
But I had it for about two years.
Once you get rid of it.
Well I was married at the time and that
thing was hard when I would leave and
she'd had that car.
It was just hard to back into the,
the garage or any,
we have a small two door to two car garage
and it was hard to get that thing in
there. And so she, she, she
convinced me that we didn't need it.
We leased a Lexus Rx rx three 50 for
awhile. Those are dope. I liked them.
I like it when you drive it like
the backup camera and those things.
That's very nice.
Yeah.
We drive a truck and then you get into
a little car like that. You're like,
oh yeah. I was like a dancer, right?
Yeah.
What was your first car?
My first car was a 1973 Chevelle Chevelle,
s.
S it was a shitbox.
I drove it from the guy's house to
my house and then it died. It never,
it never worked again.
I take,
I drove to my girlfriend's house and
then I drove back to my house and then it
died, and then I called the guy up,
my hand, me your fucking car died.
He came and gave it. He gave me the
money back and took his car. He said,
what happened to my car? I'm like,
a died. Just doesn't work. Wow.
Like a day. I had it for a
day and then my was horrible.
Yeah.
Then I had a 1968 four four two that
are wrapped around a telephone pole.
Oh Shit. Yeah. Whoops.
Hydroplaned yeah. Yeah.
If you didn't know how to drive back
then and you had to like kind of balding
tires. Yeah. And you hit some water. Yeah.
Cars would just go sideways
and you know what is this like?
You're floating in there. Yeah.
It's crazy. It's a crazy feeling.
You can't do anything about it.
Nothing about it.
They always tell you to turn
until it nothing's happening.
I was just going sideways. I was
like, I can't believe this shit.
I just got this car. I had that
one for a few months and then bang,
fucked that one up. Just hydro
planning. Just hung by yourself. No,
I was with a couple of guys from a school.
He might get hurt. No, we're all right,
but it fucked the car up. I was in
a fee era member fee arrow. Yeah.
My sister had one of those. It's like
a little key chain Ferrari. Yeah.
Remember they used to do so small. These
are do Ferrari kits for those. Yes.
It turned into a fake Testarossa.
Yeah. Put a car on there.
Yeah. Those were, those were interesting.
My friend Joe had with those two.
Those were cool little cars.
Jim Carr, right back in the day.
It was like either in my
hometown. It was like, it is
ridiculous car. Great.
Then this is adorable.
Those cars are so gross when people do
that. Yeah. And it's obvious what's like,
what do you, no one wants that once
you get is that one that can't that
great job. That's crazy. That one actually
looks good. Yeah. What kind of tricks?
I'm really dumb girls with that.
You go to Miami,
you let me see your cell
phone or the really dumb ones.
Like if that's like, if you were only
looking for really dumb gals. Yeah.
That's your car. Dumb gold
diggers. Those louvers. What is,
what does that in the back?
Yeah. It looks like, yeah.
It's probably a plastic rear window.
Oh my God.
They make some cars with plastic windows
just to save weight. Okay. Relax.
Relax with that. Yeah. We,
uh, my buddy and I, he,
he had one of those, we hydroplaned
spun around a couple of times,
totaled it,
hit another car that was parked at a
body shop and they had just finished it.
He's like, cool. Uh, I
guess I'm doing two cars
fixed. Totaled by slamming into a car that
was just finished at a body shop. Yeah.
It was a Sarah Uber is that guy's friend.
Get on Uber. Yeah. I love Uber. I wonder
how much that's preventing drunk driving.
I just had this conversation.
Yeah.
I think what mothers against
drunk driving mad, you know,
maybe even the government should like
kick in. You'd be like, you know,
these guys are saving lives.
Yeah. For sure. If you get,
cause if you're not doing that, then
you're drinking and driving most likely,
most likely. So it gives you
a real easy option. Yeah.
And it's so quick. It's so convenient.
You don't have to pull cash out. It's,
it's great. It's kind of a weird
organization of both of them.
It's like they're trying to figure out
if their employees or their contractors
and then there's like this fact that
you're just getting into someone's car.
You don't know them. Yeah. Yeah. I
mean you assume that if you get a limo,
but there's a background check, right?
If you get a cab, you living on the edge.
Right. That's how I was going to
say. If he never know Robert De Niro,
you look at me. Yeah, we're not talking
about a fucking psychopath. Right.
That's what you like. But you will get
caught like New York City cab drivers,
you'd get characters and you get either
like a angry white dudes or like a guys
who come from other countries. I
can tell you cool stories. Yeah,
you get like characters,
weird smells and shit crazy smells,
lots of weird music but
possibly a Voodoo doll.
But now you know what you get when
you get in New York City cab driver,
you get advertisements and you'd screens
like they have little laptops facing
and the play these these credit card
machine back there and they play these,
these videos about things
about restaurants and this
and that shows that it's
its own network at this point.
Yeah, like just the cab network.
It is kind of right. It must be, but yeah,
I've seen that the copy has their own
little loop that they plugged Jimmy Fallon
and I mean I've seen him down
there many times doing stuff.
I remember they used to do the HBO
show Taxi Cab Confessions. Yeah.
That was crazy. I enjoyed
that. I was like, who the
fuck is signing this release?
What are you giving these people?
Like I just want to be on TV.
And I would say the worst stuff.
Like if you're fucked up on coke and
you get into a a cab and you start just
talking shit about all the crazy
sexual stuff that you like. And then,
and then afterwards they're like, hey,
you're going to be on HBO. You're like,
fuck yeah, I am inside that thing.
And then you wake up in the morning.
That's true. We'll call this, uh,
this waiver at the right time. Yeah.
That's gold. That's a good move.
How does that work? Does that
count? If you're hammered?
I, there's gotta be some loophole.
I always wondered about that. Um,
the catch a Predator show. Yeah.
Why the fuck would they sign it?
They have to sign a release.
Do they? Yes. Or cops.
They have to sign a release. Yeah.
You have to sign a release. So yeah.
And then there's like the, is it
entrapment and even, you know,
there was that whole thing too.
Well that show's definitely entrapment,
but it's entrapment. I support.
Yeah, totally. I supporting
Trapman if it's like,
Hey, do you want to fuck a six year
old? And they're like, Yo, do okay.
Get in the cage fucking piece
of shit. That's right. Yeah.
This is starting to trap me in the hall
for you in a fucking anybody under 18.
Right.
Or how do they get away with that?
How do they get them showing their face?
Maybe because they were proven guilty.
You waived your rights, but just by being
guilty, you have no rights when you're,
I don't fell it. Right. Thank you. And
you're selling, you have no rights.
Is that right? Well, you
have rights. Bernie Sanders
wants you to be able to vote,
even if you're a terrorist. If
you've seen that, he's like, yeah,
anybody in jail for anything. He's was
like, you should still be able to vote.
Like, whoa. Okay. I don't know. There's
a lot of people in jail. That's true.
What if they count as residents
of the state? Like it have.
You have like a maximum security
prison somewhere. Right?
And these prisoners have everything
like they have all day, right? Yeah.
Then what I need to do, and they
registered to vote while they're in there.
If you have a few hundred
thousand prisoners, yeah.
You literally can shift an election
one way or the other. That's true.
All you'd have to do is get
into that prison and go, hey
guys, here's the deal. Um,
I'm, I'm for shortening your
fucking sentences. Okay? Yeah.
I'm forgetting you better lawyers. People
would start campaigning and prisons.
That's legit, man. Yeah.
Like these laws are bullshit and you
can bribe him real easy with the little
ketchup. Cigarettes.
Cigarette, bring in cigarettes,
trucking cartons of cigarettes. How did
you win this election? Marlboro reds.
What's that guy's name? Booted.
Judge. Judge. Judge, what's his name?
How do you say his name? Tulsi.
Gabbers my girl. I'm voting for her.
I decided I liked her. I met her in
person cause it, I don't know. I give up.
I give up and not paying attention.
Anything else? Telson Gabbert uh,
but um, if you could go into
a prison, like what is a,
what's a B? What's a giant prison
population? What's the biggest,
biggest one? I don't know. We think
the biggest one is the biggest one. Uh,
I don't know if it be in New
York, California. There was
not what? It isn't there?
A giant one in Colorado that Joey
was talking about. There's a,
they take the serial killers.
They stopped him on the ground.
Like what is the, that, what's the
biggest one? Uh, 2004 he looks at, okay.
Did you say 50,000 prisoners?
I don't know much about that.
That's probably a lot of people think
about spread up all Rina, right?
Yeah, that's true. Okay. Well No.
Okay. 50 60,000 the biggest one.
The biggest? Yeah. What's
the smile? It's, well,
it was probably some Odin
rinky dinky mass, but a bit,
I'm not gonna stay in jail.
No. Yeah, I'm going to
say a little lighter.
I'm going to say thirty thousand
thirty thousand the biggest,
they put money on this. I'll put a
dollar on this. I don't give a fuck, bro.
I'll put, I'll bet you a Heineken double
zero shit. We got too rich for my blood.
What do we got?
Jimmy's confused.
I have to be very specific about
what I look up to find the answer.
So do you want largest maximum
security? Sure. Yeah. Killers.
Not people who smoke weed
known as Alcatraz of the south.
The Louisiana state penitentiary.
We go has it inmate
population of 5,000 that's it.
Damn. That's maximum
security. So like criminals,
if you go a little bit less than it
might be a little bit higher, but okay,
let's go with thieves.
Let's go with a medium security
or maximum is like violent prison.
Yeah, the biggest prison. The largest
prison. That's one thing that popped up.
Give maybe we're way off 5,000
is a lot because it looks bigger.
The X and Florence supermax prison,
there's one old supermax prison.
That's the one I think you're
talking about. It's even higher,
but that would probably have way less
people trying to see if it says, oh,
that's even higher criminal level.
That was like where they put the ice 23
hours a day. Tom Single cell confinement.
Um,
5,000 is a lot of people can find me
as so weird cause like we're just,
we're killing you,
but we're just killing you with nature.
We're going to kill you with
old and shitty nutrition
and just can keep you on a
box with your own brain and that weird.
Yeah.
It's like it might be more cruel to put
someone into a small cage for 23 hours a
day. Then instead to just killed him? I
think so, yeah. Have you just kill you?
It's over with. Yeah. And
you're saying it's suffering?
Yeah, hundred percent yeah.
100%. Like that was uh, my, my take on uh,
Chelsea manning who's now free. Yeah.
Like they tortured her. They tortured.
They did?
Yeah.
She was naked in a cage
by herself for years.
I think it was like the,
the hole she was in solitary
when I have to find the sound.
Once Jamie's telling with this search,
I'm like looking around as a,
the one in California has male only
where Manson is, it's got 3,500.
There's one in Illinois, medium
security. It's got a thousand.
Okay.
So we're way off by a factor.
So pessimistic thought it was going
low and I was off by a factor of 10.
I don't know if it's
counting then too. There's private ones
and I don't know if I can get the numbers
private, those dirty bastards
stuff. I mean on top of each other.
It's called the ones make sense.
If there were 30,000 inmates in one place,
a man,
it would be hard to contain
that and control that. Yeah.
What's the largest
private prisons if that's,
yeah, so, but the Chelsea manning thing,
she was in solitary confinement
when she was still a Duke.
Does that count like a,
as her being like kind of two different
studies say that you say Bradley or do
you see Chelsea when she hadn't
changed yet? I think we have to ask,
can you still say Bruce Jenner won
the Olympics or did you say Katelyn?
Well Bruce, when they limpic
no, no, no. Kaitlin. What
does it say? He's Caitlyn now.
You can't get it now.
You know if you dead name him,
you'll get kicked off of Twitter. Dead
naming. Do you know the dead naming is no,
I never heard of it. You didn't know.
So say if you become Joe Honda a reap,
if you decided at this stage of the game,
you know what?
Fuck hammies and transitions. Yeah, I'm,
I'm, I'm wearing time for Prius. Yeah,
it was time to get my legs
waxed. The, what do we got?
Reeves County detention complex.
And pesos.
Texas has a combined capacity of 3,763
prisoners in it's three sub complexes.
Wow. So that's probably about
as big as it gets. Yeah.
Does that car and you still can't
get anything over 5,000. Yeah.
So it's in the 30s 3,300
6,500 what about the world?
So if you, you've changed
your name of Joel Rape and uh,
I started saying, Hey John Reape
what's it like wearing dresses?
Pretend you're a girl
that's dead naming you.
I dead name new cousin called you John
Because I choose name is Joe Hahn rat.
Right? Well, but, but Bruce Bruce is
the one who won the Olympic. Yeah,
but that's his dead name. Well that's
what he was going to be an asshole. John,
you're so insensitive. So I believe
this. I hate in this day and age,
I'm gonna make you subscribes to list
them in the hall. It Alondo podcast.
Get your shit together. Shit.
You need to get up times, Bro.
So way behind.
I was just kidding about Moses a moron.
I don't know what she's
doing. Yeah, I don't either.
It was a good name though to
throw around. Yeah. Alyssa Malanda
cause she has, she's active on the, on
the Twitter sphere. I believe so, yes.
She's very political. Yeah.
She's always arguing with people.
I think that was one of them. People,
you know, they, they booted Jon Woods,
you know, Jon Woods, the actor,
they booted him off the Twitter can.
What's happened? Naughty. I don't think
he did anything that big a deal. What it,
first of all his jobs,
refresh my memory. I'm sorry.
John Woods. People probably be
mad if they probably know this,
but New York City's Rikers island as a
population of 11,000 but I don't know if
that,
they're all prisoners are not what I
mean like there's probably workers that
live on the red hat.
Do they really?
It says it can get accommodated
to 15,000 prisoners.
15,000 prisoners.
Yeah.
Now we're in the neighborhood is when
a Turkey that's got 10,900 wow. Okay.
So that's about as big as it gets. That's
a lot though. If you go to a theater,
like if you did an arena like 15,000
peoples like Madison Square Garden,
that's all a lot of fucking criminals.
Yeah.
You got a baton. So the,
the Chelsea manning thing,
like now she's free, but then she got
locked up again for contempt of court.
But I think when she was locked
up in solitary confinement,
they took away her clothes.
They wouldn't let her have closed because
they thought she was suicidal. Really?
It's just an excuse. So when they, okay.
So when the quiche household was a male,
he's in a Bradley. I'm trying
to know. They don't do it. What?
So when Chelsea won the
Olympics, Yeah. Um, was,
that was what she chose me.
I tend to do that.
Let's see. In a male prison. That's a
good question. And then as a female,
does he go to a female prison? That's
a good question. Okay. I don't know.
Maybe that's why they put her
in solitary. Oh, right, right.
Protected from toots. Then that's
kind of a loophole that, uh,
let's say if I know I'm going to prison
and I got like a year before I get
sentenced, I might just go ahead get
that sex cig. So I'm with females.
Right. I Dunno. Maybe change anymore.
You just have to identify. Oh, okay. There
you can. Oh, good. Did you see that? Um,
male who identifies as a female just
broke all these world records and
weightlifting, the new one that
just came out. Wonderful. That's,
congratulations everybody.
You broke everything.
I fucking so progressive and so
preposterous that we broke everything.
You have men that are women when women's
world records in fucking weightlifting,
which is the dumbest shit for men and
women to compete against this every one
thing. Even though I like the tennis
argument, it's like, well, you know,
Billie Jean King beat Bobby Riggs.
Yeah. But Bobby Riggs was 55.
She was 29 and they say that he threw
the match because he bet against himself.
Oh, right. He was a big gambler.
That was what I heard. Yeah.
I would say that too of I lost. Yeah. You
know, I would say a through the match.
Yeah. Well, yeah. Basketball is
tennis. The woman, the one, yes.
Says Chelsea. This is uh, the women who's
winning says not Bruce Jenner records.
Okay, let's get a look. Oh
my God. Here we go. Huh.
That seems like a very strong man.
Yeah. So rich, how much weight is that?
It doesn't look very, a lot of weight.
So listen, this is all about,
this is about reps here. Yeah.
It's 300 303 15 yeah.
Okay.
That's as ridiculous amount of weight
for a woman lift and to [inaudible].
You're going to be a real woman,
a biological woman. Excuse me.
And lift that kind of weight. You have to
be a real outlier. Yeah. It's very rare.
Yeah. But this is so ridiculous.
Wow. What is this? This is,
what is this guy's quote? What does
it say? One guy that comment say,
congratulations on your
excellent performance. Screw.
Anybody who tries to knock achievements,
the hard work speaks for itself. Hey,
whoever you are, fuck you. Yeah.
Fuck you. And your nonsense here.
The reason why they shit is happening in
the first place because people tolerate
this and that is nuts.
If you,
if you had a daughter that trained her
whole life to be a weightlifter and she's
really into it and this
fucking guy decides,
he identifies as a woman and then
compete as a woman in weightlifting,
it's just fucking stop.
Everybody just stopped.
You're in crazy town. This is
officially crazy out. Yeah,
out of our fucking mind. How it's
legal. What time was it legal.
It has nothing to do with
being open minded or tolerant.
It has something to do with logic.
Just basic reason. This is craziness.
This is you're enabling people to
do something that's preposterous.
This has nothing to do with being
open minded are kind to people.
I'm 100% for people being trans.
I'm 100% for people doing
whatever they want to do.
Just don't hurt anybody and I'm cool
with that. Saint Mary, but this is just,
you're in make believe town.
Why not?
Pretend you're a fox and go live in
the forest like you're, you're in.
Make believe this is
make believe you can't.
You can't just decide you're a
woman and compete with women. Right?
That's make belief you,
there's no advantage.
Make belief that's make
believe is my advantage.
I fucking know there's an advantage.
Yes, everyone knows this is crazy.
I want to see that in the
NFL. You know, you got like,
what does that before and after?
Is it two different looks? That's,
I need to see this person in a sec. I
don't want to shame this person. Look,
someone's letting her do this. Right?
You know, it's nice to problem.
That's the problem.
They should.
There should be a transgender league
or there should be some rules where you
have to compete with the chromosome,
your birth.
You don't have to fucking compete. Most
people don't compete in organized sports.
Most people don't know.
And if you're trans,
maybe that should be
something you can't do it.
And particularly for girls
who transitioned a boys,
you know that school in Texas that won't
let this girl is transitioning to a boy.
They won't let her compete with boys.
So they make her compete with girls
and she's on fucking testosterone.
So she's taking testosterone to be,
or he's taking testosterone,
whatever you want to say
it. I get so confused. Yeah.
To become a board Zur is taking
testosterone to become a boy. Yes.
And then now is forced to wrestle
with women with young girls.
In fact, all jacked. Right
Jack? Like a boy. It's like
a boy wrestling girls crazy.
Probably pop a boner doing that.
I don't think she has one yet.
You can get a little thumb. You grow
thumb. Yeah. That's what happens. Oh yeah.
The clearest gets a little bit bigger.
Yeah.
And did the ovary sort of like start
getting suspended and uh, I don't know.
They come to, they
dropped. What do they do?
I wonder the wonder that if they
remove those parts, you know,
because they do hysterectomy.
Some women when they have disease,
I wonder if they do that when a man, when
a man transitions from a woman. Yeah.
When a man transitions from a woman.
Yeah.
When you used to be a woman and
now you're going to the dude. Yeah.
What do they do? I just can't wait til
the day where they can do it genetically.
Where a woman really becomes a woman,
like a man becomes a woman or a
woman becomes a man. But guess what?
Even if they do,
here's the issue.
If you knew that a woman took steroids
for 30 years and developed insane tendon
strength and muscle strength
and then stop doing steroids,
it is a scientific fact that you are
going to keep a very big percentage of
those gains.
What are the game?
What is the percentage at 30%
or 40% whatever the fuck it is,
whatever percentage that you would
keep after you get off the steroids,
that is significant.
And even if you're not currently on
these performance enhancing drugs,
your body has been artificially boosted
to this superior level through these
drugs. Yeah. And you lose a lot of the
feminine. Again, you lose the breasts.
It does. Might not come back. Well,
I mean, I think if you take estrogen,
they'll probably call me. I don't know
how to fucking doctor. I'm a moron.
But what I do know is when this is, we're
in nonsense land. Yeah. Okay. It's not,
is it not saying that someone can't become
a woman and be a woman and I'll talk,
I'll call them a woman.
I'll treat them like a woman.
I'm cool with it and
I'm 100% cool with it.
I'm in is open minded is I come with this.
But this is, this is unfair for women,
which is what's so ironic about this,
cause everyone's supposed
to be looking out for women.
If you're looking out for women,
but you're also blindly progressive to
the point where you let and shit like
this fly, well then now you're
not looking out for women. Right.
Because now women are in
this weird position where
you're putting them there at
an unfair disadvantage. Right. It's
fucking crazy. I agree. God Damn.
It makes me want to drink real Heineken.
I'm getting B on this devil's here. No,
they just sent the stuff to me. It's good.
Yeah. Um, I used to love Heineken light.
I talk about that subject a little
bit too much, but it's just,
it's a symptom of a sick society.
It's a symptom of a lack of rational
thinking to symptom that people just,
just being bending over backwards so hard
to be progressive and open minded that
you're just,
you're giving into these extremists,
these crazy people that are looking at
this thing completely delusional. Lee,
when will it snap back? I
mean, it's common to Trump.
That's why Trump's present.
What that is, he's gonna win
again. He's going to win again.
Other who can meet him.
They're not going to beat it.
There's no one who can write.
He's gonna win again.
He's gonna win again because the shit like
this. The more shit like this happens.
There's then what's after chunk?
There's another four years,
son Donald Jr Donald J Donald Jr was a,
with a,
a friend of a friend of mine.
Uh, his name is crispy and he,
he's a disabled veteran or he's
very able, I should say. Yeah,
but he's a wounded veteran. He's, he
was missing, he had his leg amputated,
Burns over most of his body. Super
positive attitude. Great Guy. Anyways,
he doesn't get political online. He took
a picture with Donald Trump jr right.
And Instagram took it down for
violating their terms of service.
It's just a photo picture of just photo
with hesitant son photo with him at
Trump jr just standing there and they
took the picture down. What that,
what are you doing? Yeah,
maybe this a, did they ever,
when they do that that it gives you a
reason or they just do what they want?
Well he posted it on his,
he sent me a direct message about it too.
I asked,
I actually reached out to him because a,
I follow him and he follows me and I was
like, does this shit real? And he's like,
Yup. And he's super
positive about it. I mean,
this is a guy who served our country
too and he's know he's a great guy.
Like his, his, his, his, his uh,
Instagram handle is
crispy 11 B. Okay. Yeah.
And he just put it up there and they said
that they got him for terms of service
and they took it down and he put it
back up again. Good. Good for him.
So this is the photo right here.
Let me see when the acid Instagram says
that they didn't do it, didn't do it,
but who took it down that said,
however,
an Instagram spoke
first and told Fox News.
The post was reviewed but was not deleted
by the company after I found the post
did not violate their standards.
But that's not true because it's
missing spokesperson said it.
There are a number of reasons.
A post may no longer be available,
including the account holder deletes
either the account or the post it cut it.
And he's saying he didn't do that.
So it could have been something else.
Mm. I mean, you can't
prove it and I don't know.
Well did this dude is not an attention
whore and he wouldn't do that.
He wouldn't do that in lie about it.
That's ridiculous. I mean, Twitter,
Instagram can be lying and they,
and they just never really could
be a glitch too. Yeah. You know,
sometimes it's a fortuitous glitch that
looks like a massive conspiracy. Yeah.
But he said they'd send them notice it
said it violated the terms of services.
So if he said that he, he's okay.
Yeah. That's what was said back to,
I'm pretty sure that's the screenshot
you want to make sure that says you
violated something. Yeah,
that's what you want. I mean,
it's just so weird what's
going on now. This is, it's,
everything just seemed so
fucking preposterous. Yeah.
Just like on Facebook, Twitter,
all that stuff. If I get,
if it's something negative, I just, you
know, that's gone. I don't, I don't let,
I don't let people just start bashing me
on that stuff. I just, okay. Here it is.
Once I landed,
I opened up Instagram and got a message
that your post was taken down for
violating Instagram guidelines.
So did he poke post that? Yes, he
did. Oh, there you go. Wait a minute.
Let me see the dude. Yeah. He
posted a thing, sang it. Okay.
Here's what he posted.
It said,
wounded veteran violated
community standards by posting
with Donald Trump jr he
didn't post the actual notification, but
he probably didn't even save it. Right.
[inaudible] I believe him. I believe
him. I just somebody, you're right.
It is a sad, I think you also
have overzealous employees.
I think there's that too. Yeah, I
think there's a huge company. Yeah.
I mean anybody can go and get a minute
and just do what the what the what the,
what do they want?
You think they're reading Dick pics and
it's been fucking with them on the other
way. The other way around. Someone could
have just flagged it by a bunch of bots.
It's just made it disappear. Oh right.
To get a reaction like this. Yeah.
That's all. It could be simple
as that. Can you do that? Sure.
So if you just had a bought the jewelry,
I can do it right now on Instagram.
Review it manually before they delete it.
No,
cause I can just be taken down.
It happens on other accounts for that
doesn't get reviewed that way and it just
got taken down because it got flagged
to so many times. I don't know.
Well that's one thing that we did
learn from talking to what Jack Dorsey,
the CEO of Twitter, like it's impossible
to manage. There's too many posts.
They're going up right now by the
thousands. Like if you could see everyone,
everyone in America posting on
Twitter right now and be like, oh
yeah.
I mean,
imagine if you all have supernova
explosion of ones and Zeros.
Just fun all over the place and texts.
Just chat.
Who Do you think like if he
would've grabbed somebody phone,
the most popular person that gets
tweeted the most. Just looked at it.
Yeah. How fast would that go? You
know what I mean? Like just that,
that one account. Oh, be insane. Oh,
years probably goes to
people or do you just, yeah,
full still out of the people.
I follow a lot of other people.
I just followed whenever, whenever
things, someone's interesting,
so he's got cool pictures. A fall guy.
Yeah. Yeah. I just hit like first.
Yeah. Well let me see. What
else does person's nature.
They're not whack.
What's really funny is people get
mad at you for certain people.
You follow people that you
stopped following r Kelly.
Now don't tell them what to do. Right.
That's first of all, first of all,
don't tell me what to do.
Second of all, what am I doing?
Am I boosting up his profile?
He's fucking art Kelly. No,
it doesn't matter if I follow them. If
I don't, I want to know how crazy he is.
That's right, dude. Did you
see Tyron, Tyron Woodley, UFC,
a top welterweight former champion had
a thing on his Instagram page of him
watching our Kelly getting
interviewed and where he was. He was.
Who was denying that he
knows how to hog tie people
laughing at him. Play this,
play this here, all in this
interview. This is crazy.
Shit ain't funny, but hole
I sent me
paypal hall.
That's great. He's not using
confidence tonight. He's like,
Hahaha. To haul. How? Hey,
I follow r Kelly for the same reasons
that I love real talk. Do you
ever watch the video? Real talk?
We played it on the
podcast multiple times.
Real talk is one of the
greatest unintentional
comedies that's ever been real
talk, real talk and seen it. Oh my God.
What is it? It's a r Kelly song. Okay.
Where he's in an argument
with his girlfriend on the
phone while he was with his
girlfriend on the phone.
He's like getting his hair done and shit.
He's smoking stone,
he's drinking.
It's got like different outfits on
and he's still in the conversation and
there's one part where he goes,
bitch,
I wish you would fucking clothes.
Real talk bitch.
I wish you would burn my
motherfucking clothes real
serious about that.
Listen,
I absolutely feel for any person
that he's victimized you got,
but you cannot deny that.
That shit is fun. Hilarious.
That shit is fun. I'm sorry.
There is. Hold on. I just play that
triflin ass.
Flynn is the best,
best African American single malt.
Trifle Triflin Triflin and it's one
that white people cannot use. It's too,
I pronounced it too good.
They on that word.
Hang on that word as much as they own
the n word. Right. Top trifle link.
You can't be trifling. You
can't. You can't be announced
the g and track the link.
Yeah, you Katelyn. Yeah. That's why.
Why people were not allowed to use it.
They would ruin it. Exactly.
He's out there trifling
stuff. They're trifling. Shit.
He's just a bullshit hint. Trifling
ass trifling. Here's the thing,
I bet gay guys use trifling.
Getting guys will pull it out out with
him over there, but this trifling ass.
I know. It sounds like a rifle that you
travel with. That's a trifle it. Yeah,
like a triathlon.
This I travel rifle.
The thing that abandoning those good for
long range, they'll bring a trifle with.
How many people do you think had to look
it up before Webster had to like answer
this question.
What does a trifling Heifer
definition laugh,
lacking insignificance or solid
worth such as a frivolous,
trifling. Be Trivial. A trifling gift.
See chiefly dialectical,
my God.
Lazy shift list in a trifling fellow.
Trifling fell.
That's the most English things he'd
ever side. It got very wide. Again,
thing fellow. He's a trifling
fellow. Don't bring you off.
So the hair without Kathleen. Hello?
Yeah, that's a word bro. That's a,
that's a legit word. Trifling Shit.
I was going to say something else.
I totally forgot.
What did we talk about right
before two of them are Kelly Kelly.
I liked that point.
He did an album where it was a lot of
just talking. Oh, trapped in the closet.
Yeah.
There was a whole series.
I think Aziz had a whole thing on that.
I think he did like Aziz Ansari
did a bit on it. I believe so.
I know he had a bit. Yeah, about r Kelly.
It might've been about
trapped in the closet trap.
The closet is great but it can't fuck
with real talk. Real talk to you. The Jam.
Have you seen at a shocker weird Al
Yankovic trapped at a drive through?
No,
it's really good.
It's the same length as
our Kelly's trapped in the
closet and it's the same and
it's all about being trapped
at a Mcdonald's drive
through because the person in
front of is taking too long and it's like
the fact that he did the whole song is
this one respect commitment.
I made it too.
It's the whole cart animated.
Oh my God. That's hilarious.
Which one is this
weird?
Al has been around for a long time,
man.
I mean I remember when Michael Jackson's
beat it came out and he had eat it.
Eat it. Yeah, I'm I it was, I'm fat.
That's gotta to be, it's gotta
be late eighties early. Not yet.
It is late eight is real APP
real. How old is here? Weird.
Al's gotta be 85 years old.
12.
His first song aired in 1976.
He was big on Dr Demento.
That's insane.
So he was really young.
Dr Demento Demento I never listen
to it as a kid, but that's uh,
they played all of these weird
goofball, nerdy songs. Yeah.
And he was the king of it. He has a
huge following now. He's like, he'll,
he'll sell out places. Weirdo.
Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah. Well,
he's got so much neurodegeneration.
Giant body of work. Yeah.
I like his hair too. He's got the
hammer. He's a super nice guy too. Yeah.
And smart. I've heard. Yeah, but
everyone's smart. What else can we say?
Yeah. He's a good dancer
too. And accepts his gender.
He's not trifling. That's one. That's
definitely not true. Yeah. That's a word.
It's like there's certain words like
that one you just seemed so ridiculous if
you try to use it. Oh, this is what I was
going to say. Yeah. We were talking about,
uh, uh, we weren't even
talking about this, but
my daughter is watching
these youtube videos of this.
There's this young gay fellow that
does makeup tutorials. Oh yeah.
Okay. He's enormous. He's enormous.
You know, he, he,
he probably gets more views than any
network show that's ever been created.
How old was this fellow? He's young, so
he's like 20. Oh, okay. What do you say,
Jamie?
If I should bring this up.
I just put the last thing that
popped in my head during Coachella,
he got accused of being in
this viral video that happened.
It said it wasn't him,
but there's did the
Ferris wheel Coachella.
Have you ever seen that
dude I'm talking about, no.
It's a big famous thing that people
take pictures in front of. Uh,
during a concert you could
see a silhouette of somebody
getting head in there
and it's two guys. Oh, it's a
very vivid video that was going,
went super viral on Twitter that night.
And they were saying it was him.
How dare they, he's all about
makeup, not head sons of bitches.
We imply your lift ticket, keep
it clean. But it's hilarious. My,
my sister,
my daughter sits in front of the TV
cackling watching it just as it's supposed
to be funny. She thinks it's funny. She
thinks he's hilarious going for laughter.
Well, I don't know. Yeah. I mean
he's covered in crazy makeup.
I think what she was laughing at though,
in all fairness was he was making
fun of someone subscriber 6 million,
16 million,
all black.
I think he was making fun of people
that put on too much makeup. Okay.
So he was going crazy with,
she thought it was really funny.
That is fucking banana. 16 million
people and he's doing makeup tutorials.
He looks great. He looks great.
That's the thing. It's like we,
there's an all credential kinds of shit
like this that you would have never
expected. Yeah. And because of the access,
because on demand access, especially
like through computer, it's so easy.
It's so easy. Just type in the next thing,
but just what's next just pops up. Yeah.
So like these people that no
network in their right mind,
like NBC would never say, Hey that young
guy, let's get that guy to do a makeup,
show the blood, get the fuck out of the
office. You don't know shit about ratings.
Meanwhile, 8 billion
subscribers. That's crazy.
That'd be a fun game to play is like
what rabbit hole would youtube send you
down if you typed in this? I just let
it keep going. That's upon its own.
Those algorithms,
they,
the real problem is people think that a
lot of those algorithms are essentially
designed to get you angry.
Oh you pissed off.
So he wants the next thing take.
Yeah, our our children. What are
they teaching our children next? This
is the problem with illegal immigration.
I knew there's a fucking problem and
you know, and then next thing you know,
you just more and more angry.
That's like the argument with Facebook
too is that they're trying to figure out
what gets people to engage.
And so the algorithm realize what you
engage with and then that's what they show
you more of. And what gets people to
engage is shit that makes them mad. Yeah.
Yeah.
It keeps me wanting to,
I want you to fight videos on Facebook
all day. Derail and do well. Just like,
you know, like brawls in the school
yard or like, you know, just,
it just keeps going. I'm like, Oh man,
what's going to happen here? It's,
but yeah. Well, you know, I'm not,
I don't do much of the fighting,
so when I see it, it's like, oh,
this is interesting. Who's going to win
this one? And the ACA when the, you know,
with the, the underdog. Yeah.
I enjoy watching it. Yeah.
I mean, I will watch them.
I watch it to talk. It's obviously
someone's about to die. Right.
That like her a couple
punches to the face. Well,
the best ones are when someone deserves
it. Yes. So those are the ones you enjoy.
Someone's being a real dick.
Yeah. Someone's like, listen
man, you're being a dick.
Yeah. I just saw one.
There's a guy on a, it was a,
I want to say it like an old Middle
Eastern couple that are on a subway.
And this dude's like smacking his wife
in the face like that and there's this
other guys he's across from him and
he's recording it and he's like, no,
not not in front of me.
And he walked over there and say,
he told him like eight times to stop
and then just a punching the shit out of
him. So it's nice to see that. You
know, that is, yeah. There's one, uh,
of a guy that uh,
Kinda,
it's like a bus and some guys running
his mouth to this old white guy who's
obviously a like a x Vietnam vet and he's
telling him like, just leave it alone,
then leave it alone.
And he comes down in there and then he
walks up to the front and he just beats
the shit out of him and,
and,
and you just see blood coming out
of his face and it's like, you know,
he started this,
he engaged that whole thing.
The guy was walking away and then
he goes back up to ones. Yeah,
those are the best ones. Yeah.
When someone deserves it. Yeah.
How many, like that's the thing about
like a guy smacking his wife in public.
Yeah.
Like how often does he smack her that
he's so confident that he'll just smack
her and say to everybody,
right. Like it's, it must be,
he must think it's acceptable and
everyone else was cool with it. Know,
I must think that he could just
get away with things. Yeah.
Sometimes people just think they can
get away with things. Yeah. It was a,
there was not many people
on that bus in this video.
I wasn't even paying
attention to him or that.
Most people just going to be too
scared to say anything. Yeah.
That's what I mean.
Death.
This is where it gets real scary because
that is the best argument for the end
of all privacy is that no one would
ever be able to do anything like that
because the whole world will be watching.
Yeah, exactly. Honest like you, you
might, it depends on what kind
of action you could take. Yeah.
If you could literally see everything
that's happening at any time,
everywhere in the world. Ah, yeah.
We'll not, everyone's got cam. So it's
like it's close. It's close. Yeah. Right.
And then they're gonna have those
fucking foldable things. Cops on us.
You're keeping the people on.
It's now a little bit until
too much alcohol's involved.
That was something to it
because if you think about La,
like Kennedy did a speech on secrecy.
It was like in 1961 or 62
about how apporach secrecy is,
how dangerous it is for a free society.
And uh,
they're basically talking about
secret societies and secret, you know,
packs and the government.
And he was basically,
I think a lot of it was him talking
about some of the shady shit that he
experienced and intelligence
agencies and Oh,
but when you have like kings or when
you have people that are in power,
like how do they wield that power?
One of the ways they will their pie.
It's all secrecy. If they want to execute
people and then I kill people with,
it's all secret. No one, the world is not
privy to it. Like what happened to them?
They,
they took him to a bunker somewhere and
they're beating the shit out of him.
Torturing them. Like North
Korea. Yeah, exactly.
They're just isolated from the rest of
the world and who knows what the hell
he's doing over there. So if we just
know the stuff that he allows us to know.
Yeah. No, that's the perfect
example of power and secrecy, right?
Yeah.
Like do they just take you and make you
disappear that he's executed a bunch of
people? Oh yeah. The, we don't even know.
I'm sure that over close to
the tip of the iceberg on that,
I'm sure that still goes on
here too. Oh yeah. I'm sure.
I'm sure people are killing people
for someone right now. You know?
And some of them deserve it. Yeah.
Give him an extra one for me. Right.
Stopping a triathlon.
It's,
it's also weird like what we'll
accept people dying from like a,
I was listening to his podcast where a,
this wolf lady,
she's a wolf biologist who was talking
to my friend Steve Rinella on the
mediator podcast and she was talking
about how we accept people getting killed
by mountain lions. Yeah. Like it's, it
happens tapping twice last year. Right.
It happens. It's not, it's not
really common, but it happens.
But the moment that people start
getting killed by wolves in America,
people are going to get
furious. Really? Yeah.
Cause when they reintroduced wolves
all the 1994 that's right. Also that,
so that's a, they're outraged
that we did that too. Yeah.
Well she was basically,
they were sent, it was,
there was two really interesting
things about the podcast,
have a lot of really interesting things,
but two that really stood out
was one that the, these people,
they reintroduced these animals in 1994
but there were already some wolves here
and the wolves would have probably
eventually made it down there.
Was in Yellowstone,
right? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But that we aren't w because the fact
that they brought him in and it wasn't
just a natural, oh, we have this
thing like, oh, so many ruined this.
Somebody fucked this up.
Yeah.
And the other thing is that they
number them instead of name them.
Because if you name them,
it's like there's Delores,
Delores killed some sheep,
we're going to have to take her out
and wow, we can't kill the Doris,
but a number three wolf one five,
seven, right? Yeah. Yeah, that's true.
That's like inmates in prison. You
just give him numbers. Exactly.
It's easier to kill him. Easier to
treat them like cattle. Right. So,
but we did the one guy killed that
mountain land. He fought back. Yeah.
That story turned out to be
horse shit. I sat right. Yeah.
That the male lion was one kid who was a
real kitten and had been separated from
its mom. I think his mom
got killed. It was really,
really small and really young. So it
wasn't like, I mean, he might attack,
who knows? Yeah. Well he's, yeah,
he's a bitch. I don't know if he's
listening right now. I'm sorry bro.
But I think what happened,
you were alive and were happy to live.
You better not touch wolves,
buddy.
I think it maybe it was starving to
death and it took a chance to try to kill
him. Yeah, that's possible too. But it
was really small. It's like 30 pounds,
which still a 30 pound cat.
It's fucking terrified.
I'd never saw pictures of the cat.
No,
I never saw it either because something
had ate a lot of it by the time. Well,
okay. Yeah. So did he say how he did it?
Did he put it in like a choke hold
or did he choked it? Oh, right.
Stepped on it. Something
like that. I don't man. Yeah.
Can I ask you if you saw this
thing going around the Internet,
about this wolf pack being tracked or the,
it's actually six of my shit.
It's like a moving gif over time, but
oh yeah. I have seen this. It's amazing.
It shows how they never cross territory's.
Oh, cool. Six different packs,
I would think. Yeah. They all
established their territory.
They mark their territory and they
respect. They'll respect it. Yeah.
It's like over Minnesota. Minnesota
has a shitload of wolves apparently.
If it keeps going and it's a picture of
Jimi Hendrix. Wisconsin has a shit, right?
If you pull back further.
Yeah.
Wisconsin is a shit load of
wolves apparently like thousands.
Yeah.
I could see that and it's a lot of
no woods up there and just land.
Not, not many major cities. I freak out
saw once, I think I saw a wolf ones,
but it was like in the
wild. Yeah, it was big.
It was a either a coyote
or was a wolf with a thing.
Might've been a wolf because it was a
just getting dusk and I was in Alberta and
I saw this thing run across
the road. I was like, damn,
might've been a wolf. Yeah,
but if you see a wolf,
that's the spooky thing is what do
they do when they circling you? Yeah,
the checking you out and they're
not usually a long right.
Those are the lone wolf, but that's
rare. That's an asshole. He's a guy.
Get kicked out. You ever seen
this video? This one's great.
Look at the sides of this thing. Comes
out of the woods, walks across the street.
Look at this. Jesus. That's a bear.
That's such a big wolf.
That's a bear.
No, that's a wonder what that is. That
it's a big ass wolf. That's what that is.
That's probably 130 pound wolf
or something. Where is this?
If I had a guest does this Canada,
Russia. It's gotta be Russia.
That's a gigantic wolf rushes head.
Real legitimate problems with wolves were
in Siberia. They have these super pacs.
They would get together like,
cause they were starving so you get like
a hundred wolves would form a super pac
because they could kind of do whatever
the fuck they want and once they get that
bang and they started killing horses.
Yeah, go on a horse stables to just
tick down a horse. Easy. Yeah.
But it's just the idea that the super
pacs and that they realized it was too
hard to,
to just take over shit.
All these pesky people and their guns and
houses and that's, they get desperate.
Your fucking horses now.
Siberia has always been an
interesting place in Russia.
No. Have you used to do up there? 1990.
Yeah. Uh, right before communism fell.
I was there for three weeks. Well before
communism fell. Yeah, we do a bunch off.
Was a empower. Whoa. Yeah. Uh,
it was a spy preview of the CAG deal.
You'll get pulling in my visual style.
Wow. That's pretty good. What'd
you say? I said hello? Uh,
I don't understand please and thank you
that it's the worst.
I remember,
uh,
it was just program founded by Dwight
d Eisenhower and that four days of the,
it's called people to people where the,
they send the youth of America to other
countries to hang out with that youth to
promote world pace.
And that's all it is.
And certain kids from high
schools are selected and they go,
you got to Washington DC first for
three, for three days. They, they,
they debrief you and then you go to
another country and ours was Russia.
It was awesome. Had to add a
great time. Wow. Yeah. And uh,
I told Bert Kreischer that too, you know,
cause he has the whole machine story.
I said, I feel like I can't tell
my Russian story because you've,
you've owned it so much with your machines
going and if I do anything about this,
then it's going to look like
I'll, I'll get you too, huh? Yeah.
You got it in Russia story to you should
tell it. Yeah. People want to hear it.
They'll understand it.
They don't think you're,
I kind of got in trouble because I was
trading illegally on the black market
over there. Well, we did it on purpose.
I didn't know I was doing it. Um,
because you know, it's
both for the story, right.
Because a cop and like tell me more.
That's kind of what happened.
This dude I was talking to is after like
a, a function that we were at, you know,
with a, we will go to the, some, some
towns, some village, and they'd come in,
they'd greet you with bread and salt and
they would dance around and you would
just eat with them and hang
out or whatever. And, um,
so I was just talking to this kid, you
know, and they speak perfect English,
you know,
we're the ones that don't speak Russian.
So this kid is trying to teach me Russian
cuffs words and I thought he's pretty
cool. It's before the Internet, you know.
So I had a bunch of these ain't pans that
my mom gave me from the phone company
where she works. She goes,
just give him make pants,
they live anything with English
riding on it, anything American,
they're going to love it. Bubble gum,
jeans, ink, pens, Solo. I was like, yeah,
it let's, let's be pen pals. So
exchanging addresses, you know,
like I would keep in touch with you,
why not?
And I gave him a pen and
he gives me his address.
And what I don't know is this dude's
already kind of in trouble with cops over
there for trading illegally on
the black market. I had no idea.
And this cop just grabbed both of us,
the drags us into the hotel and no one
saw me from my group get grabbed by the
way, because I was off doing my own
little thing that this dude, right, uh,
learning Russian customers.
So we'll go into his office and this
hotel and they're just cussing each other
in Russian. And I don't know what
the hell is going on. I'm like, dude,
what is this? Am I a big trouble
here? I mean, you know, he goes,
if this bullshit not to learn about that,
this is bullshit.
Then they scream some more.
Now the cop doesn't speak English.
And so he's basically my translator
disguise to the cop. I'm like,
Hey man, I'm with this group, you
know, I don't know what's going on.
And so he kicks that kid out,
the Russian cop,
and now it's just me and this Russian cop.
And I'm looking at him and,
and he's looking at me and he looks at
my bag with all these ink pens and he's
like, he goes like this. He's like, what
was, you know, let me see. You know,
he'll call you want to pin. So I hand him
a pen and he looks at it. Is that good?
Cool. He puts it in his desk and he goes
away and it comes back with this big ass
Russian PennDOT sickle and hammer
thing with wings coming out.
It's pretty cool looking thing. And he's
handed it to me and he goes like this.
So he technically arrested me for
trading and then he traded with me.
Yeah, 1990s. When that
happened, it was pretty crazy.
It was fun to see all that shit though,
right before it fell.
And did you see like lines in the street
for food or anything crazy like that?
Yeah, I'm not crazy. Well,
yeah, we, I saw linens. Uh,
we went to red scare of
square Lenin's tomb. Um,
we went to some smaller
little danky villages. Uh,
went swimming in the Nepa to river,
right close to where Chernobyl was like
50 miles from Chernobyl and whoa. So, um,
but yeah,
there was definitely tell it
was definitely some poverty
going on here and there,
but not, not to the extreme
that you hear. You're not,
I didn't see like these lines around
buildings or for toilet paper or anything
like that. But you know, that's what I
was, communism was on its way out too,
so it wasn't in the worst part of it,
but it was definitely an experience.
I was 18 when I went over there.
There's a picture of me in red
square and w I got acid washed jeans.
I've got a bugle boy t shirt on and I'm
wearing a fanny pack with deck shoes and
I'm just doing like that.
So that was fun, man.
Yeah, that's gotta be a
hell of a flight too. Right?
How long does it take to get the ride?
We went to Germany first on a
layover there for like three hours,
Frankfurt and then to house so young.
I couldn't even tell you how long that
thing was. It's been a long time. 47 now.
That is an interesting country to me.
It's always been an interesting country
because it gets so fucking cold.
They're hard people and they
create all these amazing fighters.
There's so many great fighters
and wrestle and wrestlers that
have come out of Russia.
Former Soviet Union that can
drag off rocky five or four.
Yeah, the new one. It was scary to new
ones. She was afraid of the new creed.
Rocky's. Yeah. You know that I've
heard. I haven't seen it yet. Yeah.
Dragos son is fighting.
Who is this guy?
Creed's son till we know the
actor. The creed guy? No, no.
Think this is the son of a
Drago. I Dunno. Some Russian cat.
Okay. Already famous over
here. I like to think so.
I don't think so. Yeah. There's the
guy. Look at him. There's the real cool.
Yeah. He his son. My sauce.
Like a bad ass. He does.
He's still a bad ass. I'm sure
that his jaw was perfectly square.
That was like a dam square cut.
Much bigger Rocky's right.
How tall is a Sylvester? I
don't know. I maybe met him.
Yes. Yes. Um,
I think he's about five [inaudible] nine.
He's taller than me. I'm five. Eight.
Okay. So he's either five,
nine or five. 10. Okay.
So that hold the drug up must be huge.
Like how it tells you to say he is,
cause everybody was jokes around and
says he's five [inaudible] 11 or a these
five, seven, five, five. But they
do that with everybody. Yeah,
they do that. Tom Cruise, his
five 10 see that makes sense.
So He's two inches taller than
me. Five 10. Okay. Well yeah,
I think I'm five nine. I don't know. I
haven't measured myself in a while. Hello?
Hello. How tall do you think I am? I think
you're about that. About five. Nine. Yeah.
In high school I always put like five,
10, five, 11 you'd get more bigger. Now.
We're old people that are small and
as people get bigger and bigger,
these kids today that are getting
hitting puberty when there's six yeah,
there's hormones in the
meat. What's up? Six five,
six, five. They probably accentuated
his height for that. That single,
that's just his hair's five inches.
Look at that damn hair.
It looks like he's almost like a foot
taller than them, doesn't it? Yeah. Yeah.
They probably had,
they probably had him in heels and
barefoot or something for that shot.
Didn't they say like, uh, at one
point there in this movie, Rocky said,
go ahead and uh, go ahead. Hit me for
real one time. Just what, you know,
so make it look real because
they were always like, you know,
they're like an inch apart and the swings
and it almost hit him to the hospital.
Like he hit him in the chest.
Right? Yeah, he talked about that.
Almost stopped his heart. Dumb
idea. Doll from Jews. Right.
He's a professional. He's a kickbox
kickboxing. Yeah. Really good.
So that's the song Lundgren put me in the
hospital during rocky four. Yeah. Yeah.
Believe it. Don't let people
hit you bro. You know, he,
he also liked to realism bell, I guess. I
wonder if they even use the clip. Right.
Um,
he also has like screws in his
neck from doing the expendables.
I'll, yeah. Yeah. What do you got you,
he's put in intensive
care for five days of that
with nuns walking around.
Jesus Christ.
Wow. Insurance Company would not pay out
until after they saw the footage of the
incident. Once they did, they wrote
the check. I want to see that footage.
He said he could see that punch.
He hit my heart so hard that it banged
against my ribs and started to swell.
And that usually happens in car accidents.
Oh my God.
That guy can punch. He's a
beast, man. He's a giant dude.
Why would he ever needs a serious striker?
Like he knows how to throw shots.
If you watch him in his movies, he's
uh, he's obviously trained. Yeah,
I want to see that footage. I want to say
that punk, ouch. It's gotta be out there.
But if Sylvester Stallone wouldn't let
anybody see it that way because it was
too embarrassing,
the way cried.
Ooh.
He's like that lady who steps
on Grapes and falls down.
Oh Wow.
She loses her breath.
You can never be an action hero again.
If somebody sees you cry. That's
true. Right? If someone sees Z,
like legitimately cry from a liver shot,
whoa.
He just shit yourself and
he's looking at the camera.
Why shitting yourself is probably the most
embarrassing thing a person do, right?
Yeah.
You share like a guy who's known for
being handsome and Debonair and a bad ass
can't make it to the toilet anti black.
There's no control over and shoot
yourself in your car while you're driving.
You know,
white leather seats.
That's the worst it's going to happen
to sell. It happens to everybody.
It's going to be a time in your life
if you eat risky. Yeah. Right? Yeah.
Think of the most handsome
person in the world.
Most often the woman in the
world splattering all over
herself at some point and
her hotness hay day, most likely. Do you
remember that? Like thinking about that,
what was the Woody Harrelson movie?
Was it w?
W that was, he was throwing up it. Was it
woody Harrelson movie where
he played the Bowler? Oh yeah.
I'll a kingpin tink pen.
Yeah. That was a scene, right?
There wasn't a shit seat in that. That
was, I'm thinking of dumb and dumber.
There is a shit seen it. Well,
he's sitting in the urinal.
That's about it. Really?
Oh yeah, that's right. That's right.
I know how to do it because I
had a fairly brothers movie.
Dumb and dumber as big shit scene too
with uh, Jeff Daniels. That's right.
That's what I'm thinking.
It's laxative in his,
where he's hanging onto the toilet lid.
Like he's going to get shocked
to orbit and he's going, oh yeah.
They got all these weird noises. Yeah.
Because Jim Carrey was tail ceilings girl.
Yeah. Yeah. Always poisoned his
friend. Yeah, that's it right there.
There it is full on.
But kingpin,
was it a fairly brothers
movie? That's, um,
that's one of my all time favorite comedy
movies came paint. That's a great guy.
It's great. I remember loving it,
but I haven't seen it in so long.
I need to get looked at it.
Looked at it against,
scared to watch movies that I love again
and see him in like the light of 2019
and go, yeah, this is terrible. I know
that's happened a couple of times.
It happens. It's weird, right? Yeah. You
remembered so fondly. Yeah. Look at that.
Bilberry think that hair hair's amazing.
It was such a good movie with
hair and makeup had to go like,
I'm sure that was his decision.
We're going to make your hair
just fan out randomly up.
It's going to look like a spoiler on a
fee era before Donald Trump. Yeah, yeah.
Like a little Trump thing going on there.
It's very similar.
So as a professional bowler now and a
Pba that has a full on orange Afro right
now. Really? And he's like really
good and he's from my hometown. Yeah.
See if you're a bowl or you
got to do something like that.
Stand out where like purple glittery
clothes or some shit. That's smart.
That's just Brandon.
He's peacock and he's like there is that
dude's from Hickory, North Carolina.
So he, that's why he
wears that shit. Got Him.
Well he's gets up to Scott too.
I mean,
how the fuck else do you get
attention when Europe Bowler? Exactly.
Like that might be the
only way to save Boeing.
They might have to like go like roller
derby and just knock into each other when
a boat trailer board a bowling.
I've never sat down and watched
bowling. Ari's, he's got a good friend,
Tommy, what's his name?
He's a professional bowler.
Real Nice Guy. I met him
at a couple of shows. Okay.
But this guy's a real pro bowler and we
were talking about like the financial
opportunities of bowling
and this is not good
like pro pool players on
both. Surprised. It sucks.
It sucks.
Tommy Ari's friend.
I'm sorry.
Have you boldly? Recently I bought
with my kids as five bold. Yeah.
Dilutes maybe. I think that's it.
Yeah. Tommy glutes. I think that's it.
Got, what's your high school
with was a, Yup. That's him.
Did turn a hundred percent there's
already or you went to see him bowl? Yeah.
He's a good guy. Real fucking
killer borrower. Do you,
can you make it curve? No. Yeah.
He even tried to enroll that motherfucker
to ride down the damn middle.
I do it as hard as possible
or it's disturbing for
people to watch and now they
have it. They have the miles per hour
up there so you can see how fast,
it's like a dam, you know,
like a pitching thing.
I'm trying to get that bitch fast.
Yeah, I just want to smash those things.
I can't, I know he get the guys
who like curve it really good.
Like he goes way over here and it just
whips real fast and then a gutter ball.
Oh all that for fucking Beth.
The fucked up.
Look at all that you did shitty with
watch. Now Watch me ride down the middle.
Strack to me bowling was
always like breaking in Pool.
It's like yeah it's
cool to break the balls.
But the real cool thing
is to play the game.
Like this is you just breaking
the balls over over again.
It's the same look every time.
Every time. Well it's like bowling,
bowling, you're just breaking the
balls. That's all you're doing.
Like when you're bowling, you got
pins, you just knocking down the pins,
the exact same more.
It's the same thing every time.
And I know the combinations are different
in the way they collide and the way
you impact is different. But it's still
the same thing. Like it's a dumb game.
Sorry.
And my grandfather was a big bowler Mac
and bold leagues and he had trophies in
his house and Shit. He used to love
bowling, but I was like a little kid.
I was analyzing Boeing cause he'd
take me bowling with them. I was like,
this isn't a nonsense game.
Yeah,
it's games nonsense to get into it just
so you can smoke and drink and there's a
thing that they have in the east coast
in Boston that they don't even have
anywhere else. It's called candle
pin bowling. He ever see that shit.
It's which smaller version do
you your ball with a softball.
That sounds more fun to me, but it's
huge in the east coast. Hometown, Ohio.
They've got a few places actually.
The gigantic bars that they have all
these lanes for this thing? Yeah,
for candle pin bowling. Yeah. It's
called pens or something like that. Yeah,
I was looking down on that because I
came from my grandfather in New Jersey.
I bold regular bowling, like
a fucking American. Right.
And then I go over what's
this candle pit bull shit.
What'd you guys steal this from Finland
or something. But is that nonsense pins,
all of those things. See, I didn't
notice that. That is ridiculous.
I didn't know they were shaped that way.
Throwing rocks to thrown rocks had pins.
That's not what I was talking about.
This is really just the bar that hard.
This is not what you're talking about.
Just,
well I mean it is but it's
it's way smaller and it's
really just like a bar game.
Oh No,
this has like five lanes or 10 lanes
and he could play but but it's the same
game and see bowling in New England,
they'll have like bowling alleys and you'd
go, Oh let's go bowl. And they're like,
Oh we're candle pin only people like what?
Candled pin only bowling alleys.
Yeah,
so we're going to light these candles.
That's what I want. Set them on fire.
It only works on the east
coast for some reason.
There's a few of those things
like how about this high lie?
I'll fuck people can't go fault.
That ball goes fast.
It's actually it's way smaller.
And I was thinking in my head,
I'm like miniature bowling.
You got a little ball to just
keep ball a little bit. Yeah,
so it's Kinda like candle pin bowling,
but the candle pins,
the pins are different.
The shape, like candles,
that's why it's called candle pin bowling.
If you look at them,
they're thin pins and they're not like
fat on the bottom. That's like what?
Why are we even here?
We bolded or not make a commitment.
Highlight I think is one of the most
corrupt games. Oh yeah. Someone,
someone tried to tell me
explain, oh, it was Joey.
He was explaining to me how highlight
works that it's all about gambling and the
only reason why it works is that people
are betting on the games and so because
people are betting on the games,
they get these guys and these guys just
fucking miss it on purpose and they knew.
Yeah. It's like it's
rigged. I might be wrong.
If you're a highlight player and
you're like, is this podcast,
hey, I get my information from the
Church of what's happening here. We go,
look at that damn glove. It's,
look how they play with that.
It looks like somebody with a one long
freaking nail or they they're holding it
right.
It's not like wrapped around their wrist.
They're holding it like a tennis racket.
How much more fun would it be if he
watched a baseball game with a picture?
Just had that thing. Boy, that looks
so stupid. This game looks so, Doug,
what's the goal? The goal
was losing, I don't know,
throwing it off the wall and then another
guy catches it and then throw it in,
but they somebody here to get
hit in the face pretty quick.
They're putting forth minimum efforts.
Even when he falls down,
it's like that guy, he's fallen down like
he's trying to get a foul like, oh yeah,
he does. It looks like he flopped
Flint soccer. The soccer flops. Oh,
he soccer flopped it.
That's why Soco never make it in America.
The flop you can't get. Yeah, you have
30 years of flopping. You can't trick us.
We can watch it on TV. We know
what you do. You know though,
I think it's catching on
in the NFL and the NBA,
they're starting to flop a little bit
more because they see what happened.
They didn't. Somebody analyze
who's free throw to the analyze.
What do you mean?
There was someone that Angela,
there was an ESPN analyst who analyzed,
um,
what's the guy's name with a big crazy
beard. Really good basketball player. Oh,
from the clippers. Hope go to,
I don't know what I pretended.
I literally don't know shit.
Go To uh,
Andrew Salt Schultz is, I think
it's Kevin Durant. Is that it?
Andrew Salt Schultz's go to Andrew souls.
Schultes is a Twitter page,
so he had it up on his Twitter and I
washed it and I've watched it analysis the
difference between him
when he's challenged and he
throws a free throw versus
unchallenged when he's uncharted with
the beard. That's James Harden. Okay.
We've been challenged,
meaning someone's trying to block him
or he has a free open cup of Chai and he
has a free open shot.
He just jumps up in the air and
does this three is three pointer.
But when he's challenged,
he throws his legs up to hit the other
person so he could fall down on his ass.
I don't like it. It's like a leg
kick. Yes. Move. Well, he's not even,
it's not even a self defense move.
He's like making,
he's forcing contact with the person so
that he can fall down. But it looks like,
yeah, it's interesting. So it looks
like got file. So here you'll see him.
This watch, watch no one's
there. Watch, watch. He jumps,
two jumps straight up in the air,
straight up, just straight up in the air.
And this guy analyzes several
shots where he does this. Well,
any man's then um, then they
show when he's contested, right?
And when he's contested,
he jumps up in the air and look,
he throws his body weight
forward and then it falls down.
So in the hopes that there'll be a foul,
they're saying like if you
look at the way his body moves,
when someone's contesting him,
he moves and Leeny his legs
towards them to make contact.
Do you think that's involuntary
or voluntary? Involuntary.
You see the problem is that pencil,
neck, Dork fucking pushing that now
he's a specifically no,
and especially like in the last two or
three years for getting himself to the
free throw line. Right. At a way higher
clip than that almost anybody in history.
So like that's what they're also saying.
Like you can't fault him for that because
he's using the rules of the game to
play the game. Right. So this guy is,
who is this guy who was examining this
van pelt and he's got the heck events,
health center guy.
So the head sports and a guy is analyzing
this and he's realizing that the legs
are moving in a direction towards the
other player because the guys there,
which is might exactly be what he's doing.
It might be that or it might be that he
has a different reaction when someone's
in front of him and he almost wants
to kick the guy away from him. Yeah.
I don't know. Most Times fouled
on a three point attempt.
He has 95 60 more than anybody in league.
So yeah,
I'm going Scott van pelt and they made
it a rule to cause you may be correct.
There's a big thing that happened over
the weekend and their game because you
have to give the guy a space to land
because there are a couple of years ago
there were a couple of defensive players
that got in trouble for hurting people.
They're getting their ankles turned,
ruining their career,
which has been ruining this team's
chances to win a championship.
Lots of money involved.
They made a,
it's a flagrant foul like it's very bad
to do that and the referees all of a
sudden didn't didn't call this on Sunday,
like the very first time all
year they stopped calling it.
That's why they're talking about it
really and they stopped calling it because
people are taking advantage of it.
W why they stopped calling it is the
big question that people were literally
talking about for 48 hours.
Like why are they doing this?
Bringing up the question of like,
are the officials really involved in the
game and it's become a big discussion.
Another reason why I won't watch it.
Do you watch sports? I watch football.
That's it. Yup. Do you worry
about brain damage? Uh,
well yeah cause it's
going to really the NFL.
Do you look at a different
length right away?
Do you look at it differently than you
did like before that concussion movie? Uh,
well I, I played high
school football. I've,
I've got hit so hard that I've
seen stars and that kind of stuff.
But I think that can happen.
I don't look at it differently.
To answer your question. No,
no. I think it, you know,
they might change the helmets and
they've tried that over the years.
Do you remember like what,
it was just leather helmets.
There was less concussions cause
you would not lead with your head.
Now you have a weapon on your head and
people have used this such and so I would
love, you know how they do
throwback uniforms? Let's see.
I mean let's go throw back equipment.
Let's put the leather helmet back on.
Tech Tech Tech, stupid face
mask off. You really should.
But you'd have to change so much. You'd
have to change so much in the way people,
there's so many different factors. The
way that practice where they set up plays.
Yeah. He would have to be a new game.
I don't think it's going to happen.
I think the perception of the helmet
being safer, fuck the game up.
I really think did, uh,
you know, all right.
I used to think that a bare
knuckle boxing, I like,
they should have bare knuckles in the UFC,
but then I've been watching this bare
knuckle boxing stuff and people get caught
up so bad. Now I'm thinking, you know
what? It's better to have knuckles.
It's better. Yeah, it's better
for the fighters. The helmets,
the leather helmets were padded.
They just weren't like a hard shell.
And the Shell is what made it, uh,
you know, they used it as a weapon.
So that's literally the only way you're
going to be able to stop some of this
brain damage and you're still not
going to meet. We'll stop at all.
There's still colliding into each other.
They say these guys are getting brain
damage from getting hit in the chest.
They're getting hit in the
chest and the head snapped back.
Green's swashing around inside their
skull. Well, they're, they're changing.
I think, um, maybe like a younger,
like little league now it's like you
can't do tackle football until a certain
age. So now that everyone's, you know,
it's all flag football til a certain age,
I think may doubt that'll probably
happen. And Yeah. And then,
uh, the practices will be different
where we only do pads once a week.
Well then for the real game will be
amazing if the ever came up with something
that definitively fixed it, like some stem
cell treatment or something like that,
that regenerate brain tissue and bring
you back to your normal state. Right.
If they do that, then we don't have
to worry about it anymore. Right.
But until that man, oh, that's got to
be around the corner, that's close.
I think that's a very complex question
of how to regenerate neural tissue,
brain tissue,
how to get rid of all those abscesses and
all those things that you see in those
people's brains. And FCT, they develop
these like holes in their brain. Yeah.
It's serious shit. You know,
it's um, wild ass sport though.
Did you play football or no,
no, no. I wrestled in high
school. I was a little man.
I wasn't that I've wrestled 134 pounds.
He could have been a good run,
a bit fucked up. Fuck Outta here.
There was another dude chill.
The fastest guys are small and just, you
know, I was in that facet runner. Oh.
So fast kicking and punching and stuff.
But I wasn't really that faster.
Runner didn't do a lot of running. But
um, when I was, uh, in high school,
when I was wrestling, they were trying
to tell me like the coach, coach Murphy,
who was also the wrestling coach, he was
also the football coach and he's like,
oh, come on, you're a sick fuck. You
should, you should play football. Yeah.
And I was like, dude, that guy plays
football. We had this heavyweight,
his name is Bobby Baker. He was 300
pounds. He was enormous. It was so big.
I was like, he's not squashing
me the fuck out of here.
The hardest I've ever been hit was
by little dead and practice. Um,
probably like five sat there and he just,
he was a,
a db and it was a practice.
I was like third string
running back and they're like,
I was just running up the gut and I
was falling into the end zone. Right.
It was over.
And this k he had a running start like
20 yards headstart and it was like he
came up from out of the ground and
went foul and knocked me back up. Whoa.
And that's the hardest I've ever been
hit. It was by a little guy. So you know,
think about a few moments peto
torpedo with a hard helmet on.
He led with that helmet.
But you know how fast I go,
really good athlete can run and just
think of all that mass behind them.
Adjusted Cock crash.
Yeah.
Those,
the way those guys get hit and the
amount of force behind them getting hit,
it's probably unlike anything in sports
other than a car accident. Right.
Other than like the white
car. Yeah. Nascar, there's,
I think they should bring,
they should, uh, you know how hockey
league is still fighting hockey.
Nascar fights pull out in the pitstop
let's Duke it out. Let's, yeah,
let's say if there's a caution
and everyone else was lapping.
You've got two guys,
have a beef pull over,
get out of the car in the
middle of the infield grass.
We have a wrestling rink and it's like
full on. Let's go get in the rink.
We'll get it, we'll give you two minutes.
And then, uh, if you win that match baby,
you get a little time shaving
off. You know, so it's uh,
there's advantage to, uh,
add watched that more. I feel
we're like half wrestling. Half
your leap, right? Mascot? Nascar's
a weird one, right? Because it's,
it's obviously fun to watch.
It's fun to be there,
but it's not as fun as Formula One. You
Watch Formula One, you're like, well,
these guys are going way faster
on those wheels. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean that's a whole nother thing.
Those wheels touch. It's over.
You're in the air right now,
these guys and ask on a lot
of that happens and it's fine.
You know it's true that one wheel of
wow. Yeah, and those guys die. Yeah.
Well I guess Nascar guys did too.
Yeah. Not as much anymore, but me.
Then anybody's driving a fucking car
going fast can die. What am I saying?
But there's something, if you
ever see the video between, um,
they showed gt three rs racing
versus Formula One racing.
It's the same track and they
show a good gt three car look,
a Porsche going around this car really
fast and then they show the same exact
path being taken by a formula one car.
And you're like, Jesus, watch this.
Watch this. Watch this one
on the left and of them,
whoa. How much faster they
are now. What's the, okay,
that's the same track and save track.
Exact same turn.
Look how much God damn faster.
They are bad.
So why is that car going on the right?
I don't know, man. That's insane.
It seems amazing and perfect line.
He's cutting.
See how the line perfect racing
line is cut into the groove.
Like you see that darkness. Yup. Yup.
That's a bunch of talented
drivers and other thank you.
I think the fastest I've
ever been was like maybe 115.
You ever been on a race track? I bid on a
racetrack. Yeah. Yeah. That not, you know,
not at a pace car, you know,
but a NASCAR, but the, uh,
but the Daytona 500 has that huge,
you know,
the incline and just being down there and
seeing that standing there next to it,
like, well, I didn't know his best steep.
You have to go fast and stay on that
then. Yeah. Then it's pretty wild. Yeah.
And people get hit up there,
the bump wheels up there and collide
and fucking spin out each other.
Look at that thing. Yeah.
Yeah. That's a serious bank.
A wall that is a little turn to the
picture, but still. What is, um,
what do you think that degree is? Like
what angle? Uh, they've told me before,
I forget it. It's probably like, it's
pretty serious though. 20 degrees,
31 degrees degrees. Whoa. Wow. That's
crazy. That's insanity. That's,
I mean, if you would be nervous,
you on a skateboard on that thing,
you don't have to go a certain speed just
to stay up on the probably right. Yeah.
It's such an American sport, man.
Nascar's so American because it's allowed.
It's fuck, the cars are gross. They look
to see, oh they're so gross looking.
They don't look anything like now I'll
call how many sponsors are all right.
You have a really nice car that's supposed
to be the model that that car is and
that they can ask. Our car
looks gross and they, the decal,
they make fake headlights.
It's a sticker of the head,
my wife and put that on there. Yeah. What
are we doing when you're lying to me?
Yeah. It's a fascinating piece
of equipment though. Yeah.
That we've decided to make these things
that just drive really fast and then
hurl them around the circle, this oval
over and over. So high tech, like every,
they count every law, the drafting
of it. They know it. Every, uh,
I end goal that's, you know,
all that. But back in the day,
it was just a couple of good old boys
moonshot trying to outrun the cops. Yeah,
that's,
that's what I want to see.
That was hot rodding and it's
fine as that's what it was.
That's what I want to say.
Put motion in them cars and that fun.
That's where it all came from.
Yes.
Guys are trying to figure out how
to get the fuck away from cops.
Cops used to have those fanciest cars.
Men you think that they had to chase
people and like caprice classics,
you know that is with but bench
seats. Yeah. That is the worst car.
Free meddling with dress shoes. God,
they make them wear a stupid shoes.
Yeah.
Nike,
that's back in the day or
on the page while I taught,
I was on the ocean. It was
Daytona 500 the first event. Uh,
you know, I think so. I think, well
I'm not, no, I don't know about that.
But I know that's what was on the,
on the sand.
The first Daytona was on the sand, I
believe. So these are on the sand? Yeah.
The driving in the sand.
This is crazy.
They're not going as fast as
those cars are such a convertible.
It looks like the Batmobile. They are
convertibles. They're can wearables. Wow.
That's what I want to see when I'll bring
back the day convertible and Nascar.
I want to see these dudes faces when do,
why they made him in convertibles.
Yeah. Well they got the
roll bar. Yeah. But still,
I mean I bet it gets too hot in there.
They probably didn't have
air conditioning. Right?
Yeah. That's probably it.
It's on fire. It's easier to get out
when you don't have a roof. Yeah. Yeah.
Those people probably died. Those
things all the time. Those shitty cars.
Like if you were a car racer back
then you were going to crash.
There's no way you're going to know.
You're not going to keep
it together every time. Uh,
what's the fastest you think
you've been in a vehicle?
I want to say cause we're on the, ah,
well, you know, you don't say where,
what country it was in. Uh, I don't know.
It could be in Germany on the auto
mile. In the one hundreds. Yeah. Yeah.
There's some, um, fail. No,
no. That thing that would have fallen
apart. Yeah. Flying off the, the, um,
the newest cars though,
the problem is they're in this horsepower
war where every year they have to have
a faster zero to 60, and now they've
gotten to the point where they're,
they're ridiculously fast.
Like the cars of today.
Like if you just bought
a regular car today,
it'd be faster than a muscle
car was in the 1970s. Right.
And you wouldn't even feel it.
Yeah. You wouldn't even know.
Couldn't even tell you're going that fast.
Yeah.
Like if you bought like
a Honda accord today,
it would probably handle better and
drive faster than any supercar from 1970.
Right? Yeah. Probably fight the
gas. Yeah. You can't feel it.
Yeah. They're real. No way safer. Yeah.
Way more boring. Have you driven a Tesla?
No.
Strive that love to those stupid,
isn't it electric cars zero to 60,
way quicker than gas?
You wouldn't even believe it. I
mean, it's gotta be right. Yeah.
It's just instant power. Instant power.
And that one has a four wheel drive. The,
uh, the Tesla model s 100
d yeah. It's got four,
four wheel drive.
And so it's got an engine in the front
and an engine in the rear and it flies.
Yeah.
It's so it's violates physics that you
get like a whiplash and that think of
rollercoaster dude. Yeah. You can't
believe how fast it's going. It's stupid.
And they're making us stupider one.
They're making a faster one that goes
zero to 60 in 1.9 seconds. Oh Lord. Yeah.
It's a Tesla roadster. It looks
dope too. It looks like a spaceship.
I would love to travel. Do you,
uh, are you still living in la?
Where are you at now? I moved back
to Hickory, North Carolina. Damn.
I was out here at 18 years. Just
couldn't do it anymore. No. Well,
it was a couple things.
You know,
my career has always been like a roller
coaster and good years, bad years. And um,
I actually just admits I miss
my family. I haven't, you know,
I missed out on a lot growing up, you
know, so, and the market was really good.
I had this condo in studio city.
I bought it for a certain amount and
then it's, it's, it gained value.
And I thought, well, this,
if I'm going to do this,
now's the time to pull the trigger.
And I think I saw you at the Improv.
Why not say I'm Outta here, I'm bouncing.
And I, uh, my gold road so much.
Right. Yeah. Well that's the
thing too. And the industry's
changed. Like, you know,
I already have a manager and an agent.
It's not like I need to be here for
every little audition, you know,
I'll put myself on tape.
I got eastbound and down on a tape.
I got Harold and Kumar on a tape while,
you know,
and then now the second audition, yeah.
You fly up for it. But like, you know,
getting your foot in the door, that
tape, I could do that now. They,
it's just changed so much.
That's if you want to act and you
do so much stand up on the road,
there's really no reason to be here
unless you just want to perform exact door
all the time. That's
right. Yeah. Yeah. So, uh,
and I moved back to Hickory and I was
going to get myself a nice lake house in
Lake Hickory. Yup. Still want to do
that. But then as soon as I get home,
you know Thanksgiving Dad has a stroke
so I see that happen that you ever seen
someone who had a stroke you there when
an app I was looking right at him and it
was weird because my dad's a funny guy.
Like I thought maybe because we were
going to eat Thanksgiving dinner late so
like it was like a 6:00 PM thing we were
doing to get other people in the house
and so he was complaining all day about
not eating like I'm hungry. Where are we?
What are we going to eat? We're not
going to eat. I'm looking around at him.
He's sitting next to the
fireplace and he just like,
he just like nosedives but just head
first right into the hardwood floor and it
was like bump, you hear like
a thump. And I was like, Oh,
dad's making a joke. We haven't
eaten yet. It's a, you know,
it's making me think about it like low
blood sugar or something and I was kind
of laughing at my brother's leg.
He hit really hard,
his head hit that floor way
too hard for that to be a joke.
And then you walk over to
him and arms Kerlin up one.
I was going like that and
it's like this is a stroke.
And we called nine one one they came
pretty quick but he suffered some serious
brain damage right here.
And so he's paralyzed his left side now.
But I was in a weird way,
happy that I was at home
when this happened because
you know how we're still out
here and that should happen,
right? I'd be, I'd be hate in life,
but the fact that I'm there and able to
help mom out, you know, going through it,
all of this,
this whole thing,
because she's got glaucoma and
she's got brittle bones, you know,
she can't physically
lift him up and do stuff.
And the fact that we were in
the house and able to help,
it's crazy that it wasn't,
I didn't see the drooping of the face.
I didn't see that happen. You know, that's
what people say when you see a stroke,
you see like the drooping
happens. Yeah, I like that.
That fat chicken total recall,
you know, wait, let's see.
We're at explodes. Get rid
of her. How to surprise.
I thought I thought that
that was what it was,
but now he just hit the floor.
And so have you toured it at all since
that or if you just been small places?
I couldn't, I didn't take on extra gigs.
I, but I didn't cancel the ones I had.
So the ones that I could drive
to definitely as well. Let me go.
I have a brother who's
there as well. So, um,
but I definitely didn't take
on anything for, you know,
since Thanksgiving than it
wasn't already there. So yeah,
it's uh,
but he's,
he's at a skilled nursing facility now
and they showed us the X. Right. You know,
the, the Mri of the brain damage of the
happening at a clotted artery he's got,
now he's keeps getting UTI infections
because he has a catheter because it also,
it doesn't just fuck with your muscles.
It's the organs on that side too.
So his bladder's got to
relearn how to operate.
So he's got a catheter, you know, that,
that that's just opens you up for
Uti infections a lot. And those,
I don't know if you know, they're
like Uti infections when you're older,
like it really devastates you cause you,
you hallucinate so you see shit.
Yeah. And it's weird being in there
and you know, he would like, uh,
I make sure that bears not out there.
I'm like a bear.
Like he keeps hearing her think there's
a bear outside the window. So yeah.
That, that was happening
back home for that. But, um,
are there bears where you live? Not, no,
not, not the skilled nursing facility.
I mean, there might be some points. Yeah,
no bears I allowed to say
twink I don't tell trouble.
He used to be able to just make a joke
about that was dangerous. Yes. Yeah. No,
but uh, yeah. Hoping for the best. Still
going through Rehab, occupational therapy,
physical therapy.
Did they think that he'll be able to
recover some function on his left side?
I think you know,
that they always want to get,
dangle a little bit of light of hope at
the end of the car. Chases panicking.
But uh, you know, some people recover
quickly, some people not at all.
Some people three years later can
recover. You need a, here you go
three years later. Yeah, I mean
it, you know, so we're just still,
we're still doing all of it.
John Singleton just died from a
stroke and he was watched 51 51.
Yeah. It could happen to
anybody. They didn't age. Luke
Perry, same thing. 51 stroke.
That's right. Yup. Yeah. Crazy. A
lot of strokes or happened. Fuck man.
I wonder if those folks smoke cigarettes.
Well, my dad definitely did. Yeah. Yeah.
They said and cigarettes contribute
pretty heavily to strokes.
He used to smoke a lot when he was
younger and then quit, you know,
when he was in his late forties.
Um, but that was a lot, you know,
back then we, you'd smoke at 12
years old or something. I'll pack.
I don't know if singleton smoked, but
I do know Luke Perry did. Yeah. Yeah.
And this woman that I talked to who was
a neurologist was telling me that that's
a significant factor.
It raises your chances of stroke.
Pretty significant. Yeah. So I'm
back in hair cream, but I came,
I'm going to cut my ideas to come
out here, you know, for pilot season.
Keep doing it, right? Yeah.
Right. And then hit the
store. I was there last night.
It was fun. It was good
seeing you, man. You too, man.
That's doing the roast battle.
So that's out of my comfort zone too.
Oh, it's so mean. It is. That's not me.
No, I know you're a nice
guy, but I'm like, okay,
you got your shake hands hug at the end.
I'm glad they hug too. Well Brian Moses,
the host of it is awesome
because he's such a nice guy.
Then when he does that show,
it seems like it's okay because he's
so nice and some funny too. Yeah.
I like him hosting it and
make it seem like it's okay.
And Jeff Ross been there sort of like
letting everybody know kind of what the
rules are, you know, like listen, you
know, hey Jepson, interesting cat, right?
Like he's really created like roasting is.
Yeah.
It's like it's come back, he's carved
out that whole niche. It's all him.
It's all him down. Yeah. But it really is.
I mean there was so little roasting
going on before Jeff Ross. There was,
the roasting was a thing of the past.
It was old friar's club type deal. Yeah.
It was like old Jerry Lewis Dean
and that kind of stuff. You know?
It's kind of amazing though these days
here. The amazing, yeah, they were great.
I like those guys are
so mean to each other.
But they were all friends and they were
laughing. Yeah. While it's happening.
That's also the difference too.
It's like those rows,
there weren't that many of them and they
were friends like legitimately friends.
That's the thing. Yeah, they
already were friends. Yeah.
A lot of these roasts now it's like who
am I doing right and I'm going to come
out swinging. Yup. Me. Yeah,
me and I feel like I got to
get to know you but fuck,
I really bust your balls otherwise
I'm just being a dick. Exactly.
But it is just being a dick. But
it's really clever. Yeah, it is.
I enjoy it for from far you though. Yes,
me too. But I think it's a great showcase.
Showcase for joke writing. 100%. Yeah.
Yeah. Really good for the best ones.
Although this the quickest, right to
the joke. Brutal. You know the guys,
there's a guy last night it pulled out
a laptop and was trying to do some voice
created like you know Stephen Hawking
voice or something and I'm like,
this is taking too long. He had a, it's
not working like just the in the neck.
The next guy had like, it was like
four words. Pat. Pat, Pam. Yeah.
That's a skill I wish I had. See, I'm
like, I get up there, I'm a goof ball.
I tell stories, I am
animated, I move around. I,
but I envy those guys who
can go but a bang, Bada boom.
I wish I had that skill. You could
develop that skill, but I have,
but you've gotten better at it over
the years. But you have a style,
you have your own John Reape style.
Right. And people like your style.
They would be mad like, hey man, why
are you doing that? A lot of them,
but I'm anxious guy. I like the
guy who tells the great stories.
Is he doing an impression of a comedian?
Yeah.
But do you remember like when you first
started out there was like a way you
thought you had to be? Yeah. You know,
when did you do anything like cringy
that you look back on now and he'd go,
what was I back that I made?
I used to come out,
like I used to dance a lot.
I was the Hickory dance machine,
Korean dance machine.
I would come out dancing really a like,
okay,
the a lot of energies there. What kind
of music? Whatever was popular, you know,
something from jock jams volume to,
you know, snap. I got
the power. Oh, I got the,
it's getting real. So I come out
dancing. I made up the stupid little, uh,
I do a shovel dance or rake dance, a
mob dance, and then I would stop and do,
do comedy and then I would
get bored with myself.
And then I danced to get in the middle.
This is what I was featuring.
And then they have to get it. The hickory
dance machine. My favorite one though,
this was,
I'm actually proud of this dance.
It was any guy washing women's
laundry in the 18 hundreds dance.
It's a very specific dance.
A guy won't look at you. Oh,
it's tiring it off. Well, looky here.
That's it. So he smells it. Well,
this before the beard, look at those
Chins. Look at that baby face. Yeah.
How old were you back then? Oh,
this was a week ago, I think.
Now this is like,
it's like Russia.
That's the theater in uh, right outside
of Hickory. A place in little nowhere.
I was like 700 people. Wow. Yeah.
Yeah. Out of shape right there.
Where did you first start
doing standup and Raleigh,
North Carolina at Charlie Goodnight's.
That's a great spot.
It's one of the people love it.
It's like one of the best clubs on the
east coast to say it is somebody buying
that place? Yeah. Well Brad,
it was Tommy Williams forever.
Then he sold it to Brad Rader.
Brad readers sold it to the
guys that own helium so that,
you know, uh, uh, Philadelphia
in Portland, that club chain.
So now they own it. It's just called good
nights now. We took the child off of it,
so it's still a great club. I don't know.
Charlie good. I was some cowboy, bland.
I think maybe they didn't
like that. What's wrong with
child boy? Chinese. Great.
But have you played there
before? Yeah, a bunch of times.
It's hard not to do great in that club.
And it's also can kind of uh,
you know,
ruin you in a weird way.
If you start out at a club where
everyone kills all the time cause you're
thinking, okay, I've got this, well
it's been a week after, nailed it.
Kabod world,
what do you got?
And then you'd go to some other little
shitty one nighter. It's like, no, no,
you can't dance here. That's interesting.
Like what do you think made it so good?
Was it the dimensions of the room?
Was it the crowd because of the town,
the town's cool town. Yeah.
Towns. Great. It's a college town.
It's also the capital. Yeah. So you
get a mix of like, you know, your,
your politicians, your college professors
or students and right outside of it,
the rest of the world.
So it's a mix of everything and
it's really close to campus too.
So I dunno, I think it's,
they are just that club.
It was good at what they did.
You know,
like you got until one
night or it's a bar. Like,
I remember the first time I did
a gig outside of a comedy club,
it was just a bar is a pool
hall that had a comedy night.
And I went there on a Wednesday and in
me and this other guy walk in where the
comedians and they were
like, Oh yeah, so, uh,
we're here for the show that comedians are
like, oh shit, that's tonight. Huh? Suck.
All right. Uh, John to go get that
amplifier. So it's like there's among a,
you kidding me?
And then you have to tell people to stop
playing pool so you can tell your jokes
that right away people hate you.
Oh,
you can't get people to stop playing
pool or go back to goodness. Oh Wow.
So that was your first venture.
First one outside of a club was like
a one nighter pool hall. Wow. Yeah.
That's a rough first one nighter. Yeah.
Yeah. It had to. Luckily, you know,
I only had to do like 10 minutes, but
I, that 10 minutes seemed like an hour.
Charlie goodnight's also was a club that
had been around for so long that it's
such a history, cause there's so
many comics came through there.
Everybody came through there. Everybody,
I know, everybody came through there.
Everybody. So like the people
that lived in that town,
they were used to good comedy.
That's right. They got great
comedy every week. Yep.
And uh, yeah, and in
the 80s was the hay day.
You know what else is like
that xannies in Nashville.
That's my favorite comedy club. Fuck.
Great spot man is my favorite one.
So fuck that. Xannies
God places the Shit. Yep.
I been going there for years, uh, as
a lot of deaf teacher in those walls.
Probably. Yeah. There eight by tens. Yeah.
There's eight by tens of
comics and many of them are,
there's a guy named Brian
Cow. Kylie. I know Brian.
Colin does this is a different one.
Oh, I know the one you're thinking of.
The guy from Boston. Yeah. This is a
different one. Same name. Uh, but he, uh,
started in Nashville. It's big, big,
big guy, right. Play all the way,
like five, 600 pounds. And, you
know, he's a polite guys and hey,
I'd love to open for you and you know,
do the road and all that stuff. I said,
sure. He just show up at these gigs
and you want to go up, I'll let you,
I don't care. And so it got to
be a thing. You know, he did a,
he did a Gig for me and uh,
uh,
apprentices held my hometown and
then that night he goes, well,
I'm just going to drive
back to Raleigh tonight,
which is like a three hour drive.
And he died on the way there.
Some drunk driver hit him and he flipped
his car and he didn't have a seatbelt
on cause he didn't have the extender.
He couldn't physically put it on.
And so I had no matter how big you are,
if you're flipping that car,
you're going out the window.
And so it killed him and his headshot
hangs right there above that door.
And so that's one of many people on
that wall. There is no longer with us.
A lot of comedians die.
Yeah. But that, that,
when do you think that
[inaudible] was started?
I want to say in the 70s probably
there this started Chicago.
Nice. Xannies Chicago. There's a real
Dorfman's that's the Chicago one,
right? That looks like, yeah, that's not,
yeah, that's a weird angry,
that's club. That one. Yeah.
That one's not as great to me because
it's long and boxing and the fourth thing
you get back to the bar area, the more
chance you have to lose them back there.
Yeah. But it's still only 150 that's in
the eye. Yeah. That's tiny shit. But,
but it's, I swear Nashville
Nashville's perfect. You get
the flanks. It's, it's it,
it has a balcony right there at the top.
Shout out to the door and everybody just
has a good time at xannies. Great Club.
My favorite one and then a second
favorite would be, uh, Denver.
I was bummed out when they
locked Denver is fantastic.
But I was bummed out when they lost the
punchline in Atlanta. That was what,
that was all not anyone, man. They've
lost that went to a parking issue.
Is that what it was? Yeah. Now when it
was shaped like a barn. Perfect. Yep.
And it had a small balcony, but they
just packed people on top of each other.
Yeah. So you didn't have room to be,
you know, uh, on your phone or talking.
It was like you're right on top of people.
You had to walk through the crowd to
get to the, to the stage. Unless you,
I got that one weird green room the
whole time. Well, there's no bathroom.
That one weird green room.
Yeah. And electronic spot.
And then had that sign on the back wall
that said, quit trying to be Hicks. Yeah,
yeah. In the, yeah, there was all sorts of
writing on the wall. It's weird, Atlanta,
because we're all kind of hit.
I
remember there was an upstairs area
too where you could look down like,
it was a little about
the DJ was out there.
He had like, that's where their
office was and they had like,
it's like the heckle that maybe like
five people could sit up there. I did a,
I did a good practical joke
at that place one time.
There's this comedian named James Sibley.
Great Guy. Very funny southern dude. Uh,
we were sharing a condo somewhere,
I think in myrtle beach. And, uh,
as a joke,
I thought it'd be funny when he's leaving
to put a condom wrapper in his bag
and I go,
ha ha.
Not telling you so fast.
So I did that. Right. Did this happen
to you? No. Okay. No, but I can still,
he goes away. I don't see him
for a year or two, maybe three.
And he's divorced now. Well,
the first thing he did, this
was at Atlanta punchline.
He walked up to, it's like, you
motherfucker, you know what you did to me.
You want me to get divorced? Like it
was this long thing was like, dude,
I am so sorry. I was stupid. It
was just dumb. I already had,
I wouldn't even planned
out. It was sitting right
there. I just do it in there.
Huh? Maybe he'll find it when, as
he's packing to go home. I didn't,
I didn't think you felt, you know, so
I felt really bad about it. He goes,
I'm going to get you back.
And uh, I'm like, okay.
And that stupid green room they have
in that corner at the punchline,
right where you're sitting in there,
there's no access to a bathroom
or if you just poke your head out,
everybody can see you like who's
in there? What's going on? Right.
So I'm sitting in there,
he goes, all right,
here's what I'm going to do when you go
onstage, because he was opening for me.
I'm going to put mustard all over
the door, knobs in here. Okay,
and you're going to be in such a hurry
to get out of there and go back to your
stupid march table that
you don't have to go.
Remember that I told you there's mustard
all over this door knob and he's just
going to grab mustard on your head.
It wasn't as good as me getting to him
with a condom obviously, but he was right.
Like I go on stage.
He told you he was going to do,
he told me he was going to do
it. I said, a cat's out the bag.
Jen's not going to happen. And of course
I grabbed it right away. I was like, okay.
He's still close with them. Do you know?
Well, not, I mean as close as I can be,
but uh, we're good. We're fine. Did
you have to talk to his wife? No.
He's got a new life now. I'm not
going to be wonderful. It was,
it was the first step. Maybe so first
10 the first name. That's right. Yeah.
You're welcome. You're welcome. New
Lives. Glass is half full. Okay.
Settle the fuck down. Everybody
welcome. Do White. Yeah. God's plan.
That's right. Yeah. In a weird way. I was
like, God, come on man. A lot of ways.
What if God was one of us? He is. It's me.
Isn't that a song he used it is who sang
that song? It if Jane Osborne, I think.
Yeah. You know what's really
funny? Am I right? Yeah.
Charles born pretty close.
Pretty close.
You're not impressed with the speed of it.
I was very quick.
Look at Dj from the nineties jock jams.
Yeah.
Whatever happened to that lady.
That was a good song. Yeah.
She had her nose pierce. He had beautiful
curly hair. She just said, listen,
this is not for me.
I'd rather be in a hippie commune
somewhere doing yoga every day. Well,
I wonder where she, maybe
she is doing that. Probably.
What does she still out
there still hostile.
They're still making it every
day I'm hustling to, to,
to Allen and when I go into this,
that's on my playlist of working out.
When I get on the treadmill every day I'm
hustling. Yeah. That one gets me going.
Any sort. I got a dose Katt
Williams started it though.
Like when I saw Kat Williams do his bit
about like you could have any stupid job
and if you hear that song you
do the best you can at it.
It was a great bit and I'm like the
wasn't and that's where the first time I
heard the song I'll go, I'll walk
that. Yeah. I'm on the treadmill.
Katt Williams has some all time. Great
bits. Yeah. Especially the earlier stuff.
All that pimp chronicles
stuff is a murderer. Shit.
Yes. So fun. He was coming up like
right when he was starting to blow up.
His stuff was so good. Yeah, it was
so good. He was so way that he talks.
I did too. And, and it's
really fun. Fun Shit.
Great comic.
Uh,
so there's Rick Ross on my playlist and
then I also do a soundtrack from flash.
Gordon Queen, you know, you're the
best or, and now that's quite a kid,
but a valid, he sound check that was on
there too. You, you're the best around.
No one's ever, yeah, that'll rocky.
Obviously I'll go with movies that kind
of inspired me when I was a kid and get
that soundtrack and then I get on that
elliptical machine and now I'm doing the
elliptical, you know, for the
universe. Like Flash Gordon,
he letting motherfuckers
know I'm saving the planet.
Ever watch the old Flash
Gordon from the 1950s? No,
that wasn't the first one I saw was
the cheat Chitty one of the 80s. Uh,
I was on a plane,
not really recently.
It's like I guess more
like a couple of years ago.
And they had one of those video
catalog so you can just watch stuff.
I think it was an international flight.
Yeah.
And it had a old TV shows and it had
flash Gordon and I watched a bunch of
episodes of flash court
while it was weird.
It's weird to watch. Yeah, it's weird
to watch what people thought like space.
Who's going to be like and
aliens. It's so strange. Yeah.
I mean I think Flash Gordon was
probably from the fifties right?
It was a comic book, wasn't it? Yes.
Yeah, so originally a comic book.
See if he could get pull up video
of they need to remake that film.
Photos of the green room and the
punchline. I was looking for that
Hick slide.
Oh we've showed that before.
I wish they would remake Flash Gordon
and make it a comedy but keep the
soundtrack cause it's queen. Oh human
rights. These huge queens. Huge right now.
Keep the exact same soundtrack.
Make Flash Gordon a comedy
Jack Black get does.
Well you thinking of a Flash Gordon, the
movie the movie. I'm sorry. Move Way, way,
way. There's the original
flush board with Maine.
The merciless collide to some ball.
Let's look at him.
How Wa, how weird does he look? We got
flash like that's what they thought.
People are going to be wearing weird
neck powers in the future belt buckles.
It's such a strange look man.
It just a lightning bolt on your
chest pull up was a good deal of it.
So we could watch a video because it's so,
it's so weird to watch
cause it looks like,
what years did it say 56 c
four to 55 Ming the merciless.
So this is where he like,
it's so shitty.
Like the special effects were. So this
is not even the movie. This is the,
I know but I mean I'm
saying the claim jumpers,
Steve Holland does Flash Gordon,
Irene Champlin, Dale Arden,
look she's hot. She's hot in a real way.
Yeah. There was no faking it back then.
Doctors are calling. Yeah, same
care. I have not seen this though.
So this was a whole TV show.
How many episodes do you think they made?
If I had to guess, I bet they made 50
or something like that. Look at that.
She's got a shirt.
She is hot.
It was like a drill.
She's holding a drill.
Women back then all had flat butts
unless they did gymnastics. Right.
Unless you're some freak
of nature accident and then
that is some sort of weird
deal. Does stupid. That's
a jackhammer that you know
what the handheld Jackhammer.
It looks like that Tim Tam.
That there gun. That's what
it looks like right there.
What does this thing, this is a
thing as I do, it's for massage.
Oh shit hurts.
May I? Yes. Hang on.
Probably shouldn't do it right in front
of them on a microphone. It's great.
It doesn't hurt to feel good for
loosening up the muscles. No Bro.
That's what they had. Good
Lord. Yeah. That's their weapon.
But to me I'm gonna Punch
you in the face real fast.
It's always weird seeing what people
thought the future was going to be like
once the futurity hits. Yeah. Cause
if you think of that movie alien,
like didn't we figure that out?
It was like 2015 or something like that.
They thought the first one was
in 2000 with a soul. Yeah. Yeah.
Like yeah,
it was 2015 yeah.
It was something along like, well
back to the futures classic, you know,
their future was a, what was
it, two, what was the future?
Cause it happened in
1985 and they went to,
and the second when
they went to the future,
but it was like 2015 or
something, right? Yeah.
Something
like that.
What befell is the billionaire now because
he took that stupid a sports almanac
and bet on a bunch of shit.
I watched that a couple of years
ago at a movie theater in Bozeman,
Montana with my family.
They had like a back to the future
night where they were playing it,
you know the appointment, the old
classic movie. It's fucking great.
That won't show up.
It's so good.
It's especially cool to see an
old movie in a movie theater.
I got know they do those.
Sometimes it's certain movie theaters
will have like they'll screen and old
moving. Yeah, it's fucking,
I went to the Hollywood bowl and watched
back to the future with and it had an
orchestra playing live.
Ah, the soundtrack.
You know the movie as it's happening
and you kind of forget that that's,
that shit's happening right now.
Yeah, we do that every year.
We go to see the nightmare
before Christmas. Oh yeah,
they do that. Yeah. Yeah.
It's great. You ever go to the cemetery
and watch a movie? No. Forever.
I did a show there once though. He did?
Yeah. Duncan Trussell used to host a show.
I love him. So what outside? No,
inside there's like an inside place
where you just stand up. Okay.
It was really weird. Yeah, we did
stand out. Did that one at the center,
these concerts there and shit. Yeah. Yeah.
Well that's what they have that one
gigantic white wall and they just project
movies and everyone sits on the lawn.
It's like 5,000 people. Where does that,
I'll watch purple rain cemetery.
Look at that. I want to scream.
This is super weird. Scream
the are movie cemetery.
That would be good. That's actually a
great move. But they, yeah. Cinespia they,
you know, I was there watching a purple
rain and Dave Chappelle was there.
Um, they come out, there's a Dj,
they do stuff before and after the movie
and what addresses up like characters
from the film. Wow. Yeah. That's awesome.
Have you seen proper writing the movie
lately? No. That's great. Is it? No.
Yes and no. Yes and no. Acting is so bad.
I made great sarcastically
prints. It's that.
It's so funny when he,
there's this one when he first makes
his full face on film. Right. And this,
the movie, it takes a minute.
There's this one scene where it was,
the Apollonia is walking off and he's
mad and he just like whips around real
fast and his hair comes and does that.
And then everybody in that,
in the cemetery was watching this
in front of like 5,000 people.
Every girl is like
looking
at it. Hello. This guy
was four foot one. Oh Man.
But it was 80 pounds kind of changed
music. Yeah, I know. I was a huge fan.
Yeah.
I saw this one in a theory.
Came out was the first time that like
our French kissed a girl and touched a
booby was done this movie. Well. It's
also like, oh, and there's a lot of why,
and mine started this movie.
There was a lot. Yeah, it didn't.
He hits her in the mirror. Yeah. And
he's like, oh, I want to be like my dad.
But he actually hits her and he says,
he said the f word as well. Yeah.
Not Wow. Yeah, that's right.
I'm afraid to say anything. I
don't do it. Now you
know about deadname. Oh,
always free dead naming.
No names.
You can get kicked off of Twitter
for life, bitch for light.
I'm barely even on Twitter. Really?
How to, yeah. Well I'm, I'm on there,
but I'm going to, Facebook seems
to be where my people are. Really.
What people are those
rednecks from Hickory?
Is that more of a while?
I had nothing wrong with my space and I
was okay with my spoon. You're on mine.
Hey, good luck to all
man. You've got mail.
I think I was like this huge. Got An
oil. That's perfect. That's perfect.
Yes.
There was one before my space too.
There was the Olympic
Friendster. Friendster, yeah.
A couple of other ones,
but it was my space.
Then face what we think's going
to be the next thing. Tick talk.
Is that a new machine that, oh,
that's like music videos. Yeah.
That's not going to work with little kids.
I didn't really get annoyed
with the commercials for it.
Eventually people give
up. Yeah. What will,
the next thing will be
something in your brain.
It would be a chip that's going to happen.
Yeah.
The iCloud where everyone's just
hanging out with each other. Yeah.
Some virtual world when
you're in an Avatar, right,
and you get to be a perfect person out
there. Yup. Yeah. That's going to happen.
I'll try it out with the world
we live in is very strange.
John Reap it certainly is and I'm
glad you around to provide comedic
entertainment, sir. Likewise, my friend.
Thank you. Where are you going to be now?
He works with people. Come see you. Oh,
good question. Next I am going to Dayton,
Ohio. Nice and Toledo, Perrysburg, Ohio,
also a funny bone, and then it's
all on John reape.com after that,
Johnson reap.com Jay chairman
[inaudible] always good hanging with you,
man. Likewise. Thank you. Around
tonight. Come Camille store. Yeah.
Laugh factory on Friday night.
Okay, beautiful. By everybody.
Fun.